programming throwdown episode 176 ml ops at swamp up take it away jason all right folks so this is going to be a bit of a different episode than folks are used to. I'm actually at the SwampUp conference, which is hosted by JFrog. And, you know, a lot of people actually probably the number one email or message that we get is, can you explain DevOps, MLOps? Can I get a job in these areas? It seems like a really good, people see it as a really good gateway to getting into tech. And we get tons of requests for it. And so I had this amazing opportunity to talk to four different people with very different backgrounds who all kind of ended up in this discipline and can share their stories with us
Programming Throwdown 第 176 期，SwampUp 大会上的 MLOps，Jason，请开始吧。好的各位，这一期节目和大家习惯听到的可能有点不同。我现在正在参加由 JFrog 主办的 SwampUp 大会。你知道，很多人——可能我们收到的第一大类邮件或消息就是——你能解释一下 DevOps 和 MLOps 吗？我能在这些领域找到工作吗？人们似乎觉得这是一个进入科技行业的绝佳切入点。我们收到了大量相关的请求。所以我得到了一个绝佳的机会，与四位背景迥异的人进行了交流，他们都以某种方式进入了这个学科，并能与我们分享他们的故事。
and also explain the technology, explain what DevOps is, explain what MLOps is. And so, you know, we're kicking this off with James Morris from Cisco. So thanks for coming on the show, James. No, thanks for having me. Cool. So why don't you kind of tell us, actually, let's start off with, you know, what do you do at Cisco? What is your title? And what are you responsible for? Sure. So probably my title is technically DevOps engineer categorized right now under software engineer, which
同时也解释了这些技术，解释了什么是 DevOps，什么是 MLOps。所以，我们先从思科的 James Morris 开始。感谢你来到节目，James。不客气，谢谢邀请。酷。那么，不如先告诉我们，你在思科具体做什么？你的职位是什么？你负责什么？当然。我的职位技术上是 DevOps 工程师，目前归类在软件工程师下，这……
is a perfect segue because of the blurred lines versus everybody's, you know, constant battle like you're referring to. But yeah, so DevOps engineer for a team currently called Enterprise DevOps as a Service. So we actually provide DevOps services to other teams within Cisco, try to ease that segue for them, whether they aren't quite on a DevOps path or RER, just need specific services that fall under that umbrella. And just supporting those systems and helping those teams.
是一个完美的过渡，因为正如你提到的，大家都在不断争论这些界限模糊的问题。但确实，我是目前一个名为“企业 DevOps 即服务”团队的 DevOps 工程师。我们实际上是为思科内部的其他团队提供 DevOps 服务，试图为他们简化过渡，无论他们是否处于 DevOps 路径上，或者只是需要属于该范畴的特定服务。我们就是支持这些系统并帮助这些团队。
Cool, that makes sense. So give us a little bit of your background. Like, how did you get into where you are now? Sure. Yeah. So I went to Guilford Technical Community College, which is in North Carolina, and got a degree in both computer information systems, sort of general IT degree, all kinds of stuff under that umbrella,
酷，很有道理。那么简单介绍一下你的背景吧。你是怎么走到今天这一步的？当然。我去了北卡罗来纳州的吉尔福德技术社区学院，获得了计算机信息系统学位，这是一种通用的 IT 学位，涵盖了该领域下的各种内容，
server administration, Windows server, Linux systems, and then also decided on the parallel path for getting the networking technologies degree, which coincidentally was most focused on Cisco hardware. So routing, switching, kind of think of the path for getting like a CCNA certification. Now, what is CCNA? Cisco Certified Network Associate. They've kind of floated around. It's just
服务器管理、Windows 服务器、Linux 系统，然后还决定并行攻读网络技术学位，巧合的是，该学位主要侧重于思科硬件。比如路由、交换，你可以把它看作是考取 CCNA 认证的路径。那么，什么是 CCNA？思科认证网络助理工程师。它们已经变动过几次了，只是……
Associate or Admin. There's a few different and then there's CCNP for Professional. Different layers and, you know, kind of starts at the bottom and I think now
助理或管理员。有几种不同的级别，然后还有 CCNP 专业认证。不同的层级，你知道，从底层开始，我想现在……
they've split it into CCIND but I've long since been in that so I'll embarrass myself as an actual Cisco employee now but yeah,
他们把它拆分成了 CCIND，但我已经很久没接触那个了，所以我现在作为一个真正的思科员工可能会让自己出丑，但确实，
it's the entry level at least at the time for me which I did get that degree in the past was, again, your basic like setting up as an actual Cisco employee now, but yeah, it's the entry level at least at the time for me, which I did get that degree in the past was, again, your basic like setting up
这是入门级，至少在我当时看来，我过去确实拿到了那个学位，再次强调，就是基础的……作为一名真正的思科员工，但确实，这是入门级，至少在我当时看来，我过去确实拿到了那个学位，再次强调，就是基础的……设置
routers, which is under Cisco's umbrella. So, you know, learn how to, you know, do subnetting by hand and do it literally
路由器，这属于思科的范畴。所以，你知道，学习如何，你知道，手工进行子网划分，并且真的……
on a Sharpie and a dry erase board. Oh, wow. Yeah. I was pretty intimidated, but you learn a lot and it's a lot that still helps me today,
在记号笔和白板上写写画画。哦，哇。是的。我当时挺紧张的，但你学到了很多，而且很多东西至今仍对我有所帮助，
you know, configuring systems and having that understanding of IP communications and setting up different subnets and gateways and stuff. Cool. And so at some point you were like a system administrator and then you transitioned to DevOps. So what is the difference there?
你知道，配置系统，理解 IP 通信，设置不同的子网和网关等等。酷。所以你在某个阶段是系统管理员，然后转型到了 DevOps。那么这两者有什么区别呢？
What is that direction? and then you transitioned to DevOps. So what is the difference there? Like what's the... Yeah, so when I first started, I graduated around 2009 and then quickly was placed at a company doing title was VoIP support, something along those lines. And it ran the gamut. It was pretty much somewhere between support technician,
那个方向是什么？然后你转型到了 DevOps。那么这两者有什么区别呢？就像……是的，当我刚开始工作时，我大约在 2009 年毕业，然后很快被安排到一家公司做 VoIP 支持，类似这样的职位。它涵盖了方方面面。它几乎介于支持技术员之间，
taking first level calls, but also because it was a smaller company doing what traditional sysadmin work was then so that was something you know around the systems were all Linux based they were CentOS at the time and you know on top of that you had different applications installed for you know running various things mostly voice over IP software. So all kinds of system administration at that time, like mostly at that company, it was, they were wanting somebody
接听一级电话，但也因为那是一家小公司，做的是当时传统的系统管理员工作，所以那是……你知道，系统都是基于 Linux 的，当时是 CentOS，而且在这些之上，你安装了不同的应用程序来运行各种东西，主要是 VoIP 软件。所以当时做了各种系统管理工作，在那家公司，他们主要是想要一个……
with a Linux background. So Linux sysadmin, typically, and probably still to some degree today, sysadmin work is usually split somewhere between like you're specializing maybe in Linux, Unix,
有 Linux 背景的人。所以 Linux 系统管理员，通常来说，即使在今天某种程度上也是如此，系统管理员的工作通常在某种程度上是分开的，比如你可能专攻 Linux、Unix，
all those types of systems to the more Windows side, Microsoft side, Microsoft Server, those types of things. Obviously now it kind of runs the gamut because you have cloud services and things like that. So you could still technically maybe be system admin or some type of cloud engineer and not really be a true DevOps or DevOps engineer.
所有这些类型的系统，到更偏向 Windows 的一侧，微软一侧，微软服务器，这些类型的东西。显然现在它涵盖了方方面面，因为你有云服务之类的东西。所以你技术上可能仍然是系统管理员或某种云工程师，而不一定是真正的 DevOps 或 DevOps 工程师。
The transition there was, I think, about a year into that company was when I started hearing the buzzwords about cloud. Like the CEO I worked under was very much trying to, you know, keep his finger on the pulse of things and like to be, you know, very bleeding edge as far as any kind of new trends and try to, you know, capitalize on that,
那里的转型，我想是在那家公司工作大约一年后，我开始听到关于云的流行语。我当时的 CEO 非常努力地想要，你知道，紧跟潮流，并且喜欢，你知道，在任何新趋势方面都处于最前沿，并试图，你知道，利用这一点，
help people that were trying to maybe get to the cloud. What did the cloud even mean at the time was sort of, you know of almost the DevOps of now. People who are in the industry, they're in cloud. Now maybe you might hit somebody who's not in the industry and kind of get what that means.
帮助那些可能想进入云领域的人。当时“云”到底意味着什么，某种程度上，你知道，几乎就是现在的 DevOps。业内人士，他们都在云里。现在你可能会遇到一个不在这个行业的人，大概明白那是什么意思。
But I rarely run into somebody who's not in the industry who's just like, oh, I know what DevOps is. I'm right. So that was sort of the DevOps term then. It was the buzzword. So that very quickly led into
但我很少遇到一个不在这个行业的人说，哦，我知道什么是 DevOps。我是对的。所以那在当时就是 DevOps 这个词。它是流行语。所以这很快导致了……
some blurred lines of what I would consider CICD, continuous integration and delivery or deployment. And that wasn't still true, like what I would call DevOps, but it was starting to go the route of more automation. So less like, okay, I need to deploy something. That might involve opening up something like WinSCP and copying some files over at the right time.
一些我所认为的 CICD（持续集成和交付或部署）的模糊界限。那还不是真正的，我所说的 DevOps，但它开始走向更多自动化的路线。所以不像以前那样，好的，我需要部署一些东西。这可能涉及打开像 WinSCP 这样的工具，并在正确的时间复制一些文件。
Okay, we're going to deploy on this Sunday at some weird hour, 11 p.m. And then copy these files over, maybe restart some services. Hopefully you don't have a lot of those. If you're a smaller company, maybe you have to do that, you know, in some for loop for, you know, hours if you do have a lot. So that transitioned to things like, you know, a lot more scripted stuff.
好的，我们要在周日的某个奇怪时间，晚上 11 点进行部署。然后复制这些文件，可能重启一些服务。希望你不要有太多这样的操作。如果你是一家小公司，可能你必须在几个小时内通过某种 for 循环来完成，如果你确实有很多的话。所以这过渡到了，你知道，更多脚本化的东西。
Things like Ansible were starting to come up where you can just, you know, write some playbooks, run those playbooks, and those things would happen automatically. And so that sort of blurred the line for me, at least, in getting into DevOps, where it was more, okay, you've got your code and hopefully a good SCM, something most famously like GitHub, and maybe I have a branch, something like production or main, something along those lines. I'm working in my feature branch, and I get
像 Ansible 这样的东西开始出现，你可以，你知道，编写一些剧本，运行这些剧本，然后这些事情就会自动发生。所以这对我来说，至少在进入 DevOps 方面，模糊了界限，它更多是，好的，你有你的代码，希望有一个好的 SCM，最著名的是像 GitHub，也许我有一个分支，比如生产或主分支，类似这样的东西。我在我的功能分支中工作，然后我……
merged into dev and that dev eventually maybe gets reviewed, hopefully gets reviewed by one or two people and so on until it maybe is slated to be merged for production. And then in my idea in true DevOps,
合并到开发分支，那个开发分支最终可能会被审查，希望被一两个人审查，以此类推，直到它可能被计划合并到生产环境。然后在我看来，在真正的 DevOps 中，
there's at least at some point where you're going to merge that into your production branch, your production branch, whatever that's called. And a lot of things are going to start kicking off automatically. So instead of this guy who's just waiting for whatever time, he's just frantically logging into systems and clicking and dragging. If it's, you know, UI based, you're running for loops and, you know, something like a Linux CLI or terminal,
至少在某个时刻，你会把它合并到你的生产分支，你的生产分支，无论它叫什么。然后很多事情会开始自动启动。所以不再是那个家伙在等待什么时间，疯狂地登录系统，点击和拖拽。如果是，你知道，基于 UI 的，你运行 for 循环，你知道，像 Linux CLI 或终端，
it's going to, it should be a lot more automated and maybe have some checks and balances. So if this thing fails, don't do this and kick off an email or maybe a lot of people use Slack or things like that. We use Cisco, we use WebEx, and maybe it posts into there that something succeeded or it failed. But there shouldn't be a whole lot of manual if not any in a really ideal situation manual intervention or you know manual with some
它应该更加自动化，并且可能有一些检查和平衡。所以如果这个东西失败了，不要做这个，并发送一封电子邮件，或者很多人使用 Slack 之类的东西。我们使用思科，我们使用 WebEx，也许它会发布到那里，显示某事成功或失败了。但在理想情况下，不应该有太多的手动干预，甚至没有，或者你知道，有些人所谓的点击运维（Click Ops），你只是，你知道，在里面手动修复或更改东西，这有意义吗？那么，说系统管理是……说它是剩下的部分，因为要么不值得自动化，要么你还没自动化它，这公平吗？而 DevOps 是覆盖其余部分的自动工具链。这是正确的框架方式吗？是的。所以，这就是为什么很多人，你知道，陷入这种关于，你知道，几乎在同一时间出现的这么多东西的哲学争论。
people deemed click ops where you're just you know in there manually fixing things or changing things that makes sense so would it be fair to say like system administration is is it fair to say that it's like the part that is left over because it's either not worth automating or you just haven't automated it yet. And DevOps is this automatic tool chain that covers the rest. Is that like the right way to frame it? Yeah. So there's, and that's why a lot of people, you know, kind of get in this philosophical argument about, you know, there's so many so many things that came about around the same time.
所以当我刚开始时，所有现在组合在一起的东西，比如 DevOps、CICD，甚至敏捷开发，几乎都没被谈论过。我的意思是，再次强调，有一些像云这样的轻量级流行语，其中一些已经从想法层面被追求，但不是用那种措辞或术语。在我的职业生涯中，我亲眼看着它演变成人们每天都在使用这些术语的东西。所以在我看来，很多东西变得模糊了，因为它们似乎都是在同一时间出来的。尽管从技术上讲它们是完全独立的。
So when I first started, all the things now that sort of fit together, like DevOps, CICD, even agile development, weren't barely even being talked about. I mean, again, having some light buzzwords like cloud, some of those have been being pursued from an idea, but not with that phrasing or those terms. And literally within my career, watch it actually evolve into those things where people are using those terms daily. So a lot of those things in my mind get blurred because they sort of all came out at the same time. Although technically they're completely separate.
例如，你可以进行敏捷开发，但实际上并没有使用任何 DevOps 服务。我无法想象那个世界。我从未亲眼见过。我见过 DevOps 可能没有被理想地使用，或者缺少一些会让它更好的部分。
You could be doing Agile for example, but not actually be using any DevOps services. I can't imagine that world. I've never seen it in person. I've seen maybe DevOps not being used ideally or have some pieces missing that would make it better.
类似于 CICD，你可以在技术上进行基础设施即代码，比如像 Ansible 这样的东西，甚至可能用 CICD 或我刚才谈到的 Git 流来做，但仍然没有真正做 DevOps 带来的所有其他部分。
Similar to CICD, you could be technically doing infrastructure as code, like something like Ansible, and maybe even doing it with CICD or like the Git flow that I was talking about, but not really still be doing all the other parts that come with DevOps.
所以它们不必在一起，但在我看来，完整的方案是做一些事情，比如使用敏捷开发，然后将其与 CI CD 和 DevOps 工作流配对。但总的来说，这个想法当然是，你正在使用，比如 DevOps 最常见的工具将是像 GitHub、GitHub Actions 这样的东西，对吧？所以现在我已经有了那个合并，我谈到的那个可能由 Actions 工作流启动的合并。而那个 Actions 工作流只是意味着，例如，如果我使用早期的例子之一，
So they don't have to go together, but sort of the complete package in my mind is doing something like using an agile development and then kind of pairing that with CI CD and DevOps workflows. But in general, the idea is, of course, that you're using like the most common tools for DevOps would be something like GitHub, GitHub actions, right? So now I've that merge, I was talking about that's getting kicked off maybe by an actions workflow. And that actions workflow just means like, for example, if I'm using one of the examples earlier,
你知道，SwampUp，我想在其中一个培训中他们正在使用，这很常见，Node，Node.js，NPM。所以那个 NPM 构建实际上可能是由 Action 启动的。所以有人坐在那里实际运行所有这些 NPM 命令，然后，你知道，把那个推送到某个地方，你知道，可能像 JFrog Artifactory，然后某个系统，
you know, SwampUp, I think in one of the trains they were using, it's pretty common, Node, Node.js, NPM. So that NPM build might be kicked off actually by action. So somebody sitting there actually running all these NPM commands and then, you know, pushing that somewhere, you know, maybe like JFrog Artifactory and then some system,
然后再次，把它拉下来放到生产环境中。你可以手动完成所有这些，并且仍然在使用这些工具。所以 DevOps 不仅仅是使用这些工具，对吧？CICD 不仅仅是拥有那个流程。再次强调，通常会出现一张图表或可视化，它看起来几乎像，
then again, pulling that down to be in production. You could do all that manually and be still using those tools. So DevOps isn't just using those tools, right? CICD isn't just having that flow. Again, there's this chart that usually comes up or visualization rather, where it almost looks like,
想象一个无穷大符号，你知道，当你进行部署时，你想要那种即时反馈，所以一旦你有了部署，你就已经处于通往下一个版本的路径上，因为它是一种，你知道，平滑的过渡，对吧？所以你可以有很多小的迭代，并打破我刚开始时存在的传统系统管理员的障碍。我很少与任何开发人员交谈，除非有问题，对吧？系统宕机或什么的。这通常是典型的操作模式，而不是，哦，我只是需要一些更改或在操作上的一些帮助。有问题。
imagine an infinity symbol where you know as you have that deployment they you want that immediate feedback so as soon as you've got a deployment and you're already sort of kind of on the path to the next release because it's sort of this you know smooth transition right so you can have lots of minor iterations and sort of break the barrier that existed when I started with the traditional C7. I rarely talked to any developers unless there was a problem, right? Systems down or whatever. That was sort of the typical MO versus, oh, I just need maybe some change or some help on actions. There's a problem.
我需要新的权限或什么的，但如果他们被赋予了所有正确的权限，并且他们有，你知道，管理和检查以及平衡，比如，你知道，PR 审查和进入那个自动化生产工作流的东西，那么这就是 DevOps 这个词在我看来出现的地方，因为开发人员方面和运维（Ops）方面是混合的，因为作为开发人员，即使我可能不太了解我过去做的那种事情，Linux 管理，Linux 操作系统，
I need new permissions or something but if they're given all the right permissions and they've got you know managements and checks and balances on things like you know pr reviews and things to get into that automated production workflow then that's where that devops term in my mind kind of comes out because the the developer side the development side and operations ops are sort of blended because as a developer, even though maybe I don't know too much about the kind of stuff I used to do, Linux administration, Linux OS,
以及这些文件如何到达它们需要去的地方。它们有可执行位吗？我不担心所有这些。我只知道，如果我把这个 PR 合并到主生产分支，无论它是什么，所有这些事情都会启动。如果有一个问题，我不明白，也许我打电话给，你知道，DevOps 支持或任何人，也许
and how these files get where they need to be. Do they have executable bits? I'm not worried about all that. I just know that if I merge this PR to main production, whatever it is, that all these things kick off. And if there's a problem, I don't understand, maybe I call, you know, DevOps support or whoever it is, maybe
它甚至只是一个技术主管或知道的人，比如，哦，那个错误只是意味着这个，你知道，开始一个新的功能分支并修复这个，然后尝试这种方式等等。所以它至少在那个流程中把那个从方面中去掉了。这并不意味着没有人设置那些运行它的系统，
it's even just a technical lead or somebody that knows, like, oh, that error just means this, you know, start a new feature branch and fix this and try it this way and that. So it kind of takes that out of the aspect, at least in that flow. It doesn't mean that nobody's setting up those systems
因为这正是目前我作为系统管理员的角色所在，比如，我们正在部署东西，比如我们在这里参加 JFrog Swamp Hub。我的主要角色是管理、部署和维护 Artifactory 本身。而在某些情况下，这仍然是在服务器上。我们既有云中的服务器，
that are running it, because that's kind of where my current role as a system comes in is like, we're deploying things like we're here at JFrog Swamp Hub. My main role is managing, deploying, and maintaining Artifactory itself. And that's still, in some cases, on a server. We both have a server in the cloud
也有各种不同的部署。那些仍然必须由某人部署。但一旦所有这些东西都互联了，它们就允许开发人员进行那种持续的工作流，而不必担心这些事情。是的，这完全说得通。我记得，比如，我在自己的职业生涯中见过这种情况。我的意思是，我大部分时间都在研究方面，
and all kinds of different deployments. Those still have to get deployed by somebody. But once all those things are kind of interconnected, they allow that continuous workflow for that developer to not have to worry about those things. Yeah, that totally makes sense. I remember like, I've seen this through my own career. I mean, I've mostly been kind of on the research side,
但我有，我的蜡翼偶尔让我离太阳太近了，我偶尔会被生产之神烧伤，当我们进行时，是的，你知道，在我职业生涯的早期，他们会，你知道，每周构建一个新的版本，那是一个手动过程，有一个 IRC 频道，你会收到 ping，比如，嘿，你知道，你在这个文件中做了这个更改，你知道，无法编译，你知道，去处理它，然后它就像你说的，变得越来越自动化，以至于，你知道，大多数公司一直在推送新版本，
but I have, my wax wings have put me a little bit too close to the sun every now and then i have been burned by uh the production gods every now and then um as we go and uh yeah and uh you know in the early days they would earlier days of my career they would you know build a new build every week and it would be a manual process and there was an irc channel and you would just get pinged like hey you know you made this change and this file you know doesn't compile you know go take care of it um and then it kind of as you said it's become more and more and more automated to where um you know most companies are just pushing new versions all the time
甚至他们还在自动化失败，所以就像应急预案都是自动化的，所以现在你所做的只是编排这个自我修复的机器，这看起来真的很令人印象深刻，并且能成为其中的一部分，所以现在就像你说的，它更像是你收到一个 Slack 通知，嘿，你知道，你更改的这个文件，你知道，实际上正在这个其他系统中使用，你可能甚至不知道，它破坏了它，所以你需要恢复它，那种事情，但它现在非常自动化，真的很酷。绝对，我认为自动化肯定是其中很大的一部分，而且它现在非常自动化，这真的很酷。绝对。我认为自动化肯定是其中很大的一部分。而且它也是那种互联，
and and they're even automating the the failure so so it's like the contingencies are all automated and so now what you're doing is is just orchestrating this self-healing machine which is really impressive to watch um and to to be a part of so now it's as you said it's more like you get a slack notification uh hey you know this this file that you changed that you know you is actually being used in this other system you might not even known about and it broke it and so you need to revert it that kind of thing but it's it's very automated now it's really cool absolutely i think automation is a huge part of it for sure um and then it's it's very automated now, which is really cool. Absolutely. I think automation is a huge part of it, for sure. And then it's also the sort of the interlinking
在这些自动化之间。因为自动化早于 DevOps 和那里的术语。但我认为真正的事情是，回到那个无穷大循环图或可视化，无论你怎么称呼它，很多人都会提到。我今年甚至在这里见过几次，
between those automations. Because automation's predated DevOps and the terminology there. But I think the true thing is, kind of going back to that infinity loop diagram or visualization, whatever you want to call it, that a lot of people bring up. And I've seen it a couple times even here this year
去年。我很幸运去年去了 SwampUp。同样，这就是它们现在如何交织在一起，当它们都配合得很好，然后它们被正确配置，并且你正在利用
and last year. I was lucky I was going to small last year. And similar, it's that how they're all intertwined now when they're all playing together well and then they've been configured right and you're taking advantage
所有现代功能。你真的不应该做太多事情，除非，再次强调，有一个问题。现在很多情况下，去年 SwampUp 和今年展示的很多东西，重点都在安全上，所以现在有了 DevSecOps 这个词，以及几个类似的术语，但想法是，在我们刚才谈论的那个流程中的某个地方，某样东西应该在扫描，所以对吧，
of all the modern features. You really shouldn't have to be doing much unless there's, again, there's a problem. A lot of cases now a lot of what has been showcased um in both the last year solve up and this year the big focus on security so there's the term now devsecops um and several similar type terms but the idea that somewhere in that flow that we were just talking about something should be scanning right so right
某种失败可能实际上并不是某人技术上做错了什么，他们只是做了他们不应该做的事情，你知道，也许某个东西里有一个秘密，也许某个东西使用了旧版本，回到那个 npm，也许他们使用了一个有漏洞的版本，所以你想看到那个失败，所以在这个管道的某个地方，你要么有一个插件，要么某种版本的，你知道，如果是 GitHub Actions，也许有一个 Actions，你知道，像 JFrog，但如果我们在这里，他们有自己的叫 FrogBot，
some failure may not actually be that somebody technically did something wrong they just did something they shouldn't have you know maybe there was a secret in something maybe there was an old version used for something going back to that npm maybe they used a version that's going to vulnerability in it so you want to see that fail so somewhere in that pipeline you either have a plug-in or some version of you know if it's good of actions maybe there's an actions for, you know, like J frog, but if we're here, they have their own called frog bot that
它与 Artifactory 和 X-Ray 有很多集成，你知道，它确保那些漏洞不存在，你甚至可以有它，你知道，阻止
has a lot of integration with artifactory and x-ray where, you know, it's making sure those vulnerabilities don't exist and you can even have it, you know, block
管道，或者如果它是，你知道，那种可能只是开发流程的类型，你不想阻止它，但你确实想让某人知道，嘿，这不应该进入生产环境。这说得通。那么，比如，你在 DevOps 方面有非常丰富的背景。
the pipeline or maybe just email somebody if it's, you know, the type where maybe it's just a development flow, you don't want it to block, but you do want somebody to know, hey, this should not go to production. That makes sense. What about like, you have this really expansive background in DevOps.
那么你从你的角度如何看待 MLOps？那里的增量是什么？那部分，比如，从一个到另一个的飞跃是什么？是的，这是一个非常有趣的问题，
And so how do you see MLOps from your perspective? What is the sort of delta there? What is the part, like, what's the leap from one to the other? Yeah, it's a really interesting one
因为我一直在学习很多。这次 SwampUp 对此有很多关注。所以，我学到了很多。主题演讲非常好，
because I have, I've been learning a lot. There's been a lot of focus on that with this small bump. So, I've learned a lot. The keynote was very good
在这一点上。我认为他们在图表上做得很好，字面上展示了这两个区别。所以，对于我的背景，因为我更多是系统管理员，像很多人一样，这很有趣，特别是这个术语。
in that. I think they did a good job with their diagrams on literally showing those two differences. So, for my background being very, since I was more sysadvent, like a lot of people, it's interesting, especially with the term.
所以人们更多地从开发方面进来，想看到更多的运维。所以他们从那里进入 DevOps。显然，我在另一条船上，也就是有系统管理员背景或某种运维版本的人进入。然后，你知道，开发方面以某种方式进入那里。所以没有太多关于 ML 方面或 AI 的背景，我至少可以说，我已经
So people come in more from the development side, want to see more operations. So they get into DevOps from that. Obviously, I'm the other boat, which is people with sysadvent backgrounds or some version of operations getting in. And then, you know, the development side kind of comes in there. So not having much background with the um on the ml side or ai i can at least say that what i've
学到的，甚至在今天的演讲中，会有很多不同的工作流，所以一切我刚才谈论的东西会有更多的部分和碎片，你不仅仅会有，哦，我有我的 Git 仓库，我有我的代码。我把它推到这里，它运行一些命令，它构建东西。最终，只要它有足够的 Actions，或者如果你使用 Jenkins，
learned already and even with within today's uh talks is that there's gonna be a lot uh different word flows so there's a lot more parts and pieces with everything i was just talking about you're not just gonna have like oh i've got my good repo, I've got my code. I push it here, it runs some commands, it builds stuff. And eventually, as long as it gets enough actions or if you're using Jenkins
并且你有正确的 Jenkins 插件，事情就会让我的应用程序部署。并不是说这很简单。并且要淡化一些更高级的应用程序，当你谈论 MLOps 时，有更多的东西在起作用。比如，我是否在使用来自像 Hugging Face 这样的东西的公共模型？知道某样东西是在内部完全从零开始开发的，
and you've got the right Jenkins plugins, things going to get my app deployed. Not to say that's simple. And to downplay some of the more advanced apps, when you're talking ML ops, there's a lot more at play. Like, am I using a public model from something like Hugging Face? know something being developed in-house completely um from scratch
并且有资源做那个，显然外面有很多东西，那不太常见，但仍然有很多人，特别是取决于工作变得多么敏感，所以有更多的移动部件，但我认为想法仍然是一样的，你只是会看到，特别是当 JFrog 已经在集成其中一些时，它不应该像它在初期那样尴尬，那时很多都是定制的东西，现在它应该再次成为一个非常相似的工作流，但我的简短回答肯定是，那里会有更多的部分，你将不得不集成。即使只是从存储的角度来看，
and have the resources for that um obviously there's so much out there that's a lot less common but still plenty of people especially depending on how sensitive the work has gone so there's so many more moving pieces but i think the idea is still the same you're just going to see especially as as j frog is already integrating with some of that that it shouldn't be as awkward as it was in its infancy where a lot of that's going to be customized stuff like now it should be again a very similar workflow but my short answer would certainly be that there's going to be a lot more pieces there that you're going to have to integrate. Even just from a storage perspective,
模型比仅仅拉取一些 Python 库要大得多。很多人都用过 Python，他们运行过 import，不会让你的机器崩溃，不会填满他们的硬盘，对吧？不需要很多模型就能填满至少一个现代轻薄本，你知道，
the models are a lot larger than just pulling maybe some Python libraries. A lot of those people have worked with Python, they've run an import, doesn't crash your machine, doesn't fill up their hard drive, right? Doesn't take many models to fill up at least a modem modern slim book you know
我们就在这里，你可能只有，你知道，硬盘上有 500G 或什么的，也许三四个模型就能轻易填满它，如果不是仅仅一个大的话。是的，所以现在你在想，好的，我们将让这些正确设置以正确存储，并进行优化，所以至少比标准的 DevOps 工作有更多的东西在起作用。这说得通。所以我们有很多听众刚开始他们的职业生涯。你会给人们什么建议？假设人们在高中，
that we're right you might just have you know 500 gig or something on your hard drive maybe three or four models could easily fill that if not just one large one yeah so now you're thinking okay we're gonna have these properly set up to be stored correctly and optimizing so there's a lot more at play at the very least than just a standard DevOps work. That makes sense. And so we have a lot of folks listening who are just starting their careers. What advice would you give for people? Let's say folks are in high school
或者也许人们正在考虑回到大学，他们正在决定在那个和编程训练营之间，或者在工作中学习。你会给刚开始的年轻人什么建议，如果他们的目标是进入 DevOps 职业道路？是的，我经常看到那个问题，甚至几个朋友个人
or maybe folks are thinking of going back to college and they're deciding between that and a coding bootcamp or learning on the fly. What advice would you give for young folks who are just getting started if their goal is to get into a DevOps career path? Yeah, I've seen that question a lot, even a couple of friends personally
也问过那个问题，所以我思考了很多。我认为根据你的背景，它会真正地在某种程度上改变那个答案。但我认为共同的一点肯定是，不要认为理所当然，外面有大量的信息，无论是，你知道，只是免费资源，像 YouTube，大量的很棒的视频教你所有不同部分的知识，像你知道 GitHub、GitHub Actions、Jenkins，你知道，所有不同的，你知道，我不会一定要纠结于，好吧，我需要掌握某种特定的语言，无论是 Python 还是什么，但它至少需要一些，你知道，编程语言的共同核心理解，并且拥有，你知道，那个基础，因为无论你在做什么，即使在我所在的方面，或者，你知道，维护像 Artifactory 这样的东西，你都会有某种语言，无论是
have asked that question, so I've given it a lot of thought. I think depending on what your background is, it's going to really sort of change that answer, at least to some degree. But I think the one common thing is certainly to just don't take for granted the wealth of information that's out there, whether it's, you know, just free resources like YouTube, tons of great videos that teach you all the different pieces of things like you know github github actions jenkins um you know just all the different you know you would i wouldn't necessarily get too caught up in well i need to master something like a specific language whether it's python or whatever but it's going to take at least the common core understandings of some you know programming language and having you know the basics of that because no matter what you're doing even on on the side that i am or um you know maintaining something like artifactory uh you're going to have some language whether it's
用于脚本编写还是用于自动化，所以拥有一些好的基础，然后也只是再次利用外面关于像 YouTube 和 Udemy 这样非常实惠、非常容易获取的东西的所有信息。当我刚开始时，你会去寻找最近的相关 O'Reilly 书籍，并把它放在你的桌边。在任何你工作的团队房间里看到几本 O'Reilly 书籍或一整架书并不常见。你会去架子上拿一本。并不是说它不可用，但那仍然是某种习惯。就像而不是搜索以检索，你知道，各种帖子和像 Stack Exchange 这样的东西，你知道，至少在早期，它可能，你知道，
for scripting or for automation um so having some good basics of that and then also just again taking advantage of all the information that's out there on things like YouTube and Udemy that are very affordable, very accessible. When I started, you would go find the closest relevant O'Reilly book and have it by your desk. It wasn't very common to see just a few O'Reilly books or a whole shelf of them in whatever team's room that you worked in. And you'd go grab one off the shelf. Not to say that it wasn't available, but that was still sort of the habit. Like instead of searching to retrieve of maybe like various posts and things like SAC Exchange that, you know, at least early on, it may have been, you know,
比现在更困难，特别是有了像 ChatGPT 或任何生成式 AI 这样的东西。所以不要认为外面有多少东西是理所当然的。只要利用这一点来发挥你的优势，至少学习那些常见的工具，GitHub 和某种版本，像 Actions 或 Jenkins 这样的东西，帮助你自动化那些事情，
more difficult than now, especially with things like ChatGPT or anything GenAI. So don't take for granted the amount that is out there. Just use that to your advantage and at least learn those common tools, GitHub and some type of version, something like Actions or Jenkins that help you automate those things
然后开始玩弄它们。很多这些东西现在对开源和学生之类的都是免费的。我应该至少能以最低的成本，甚至在某些情况下免费进入。是的，完全正确。
and just start playing around. A lot of those things right now are free for open source and students and things like that. I should be able to at least break in at minimal cost or even free in some cases. Yeah, totally.
我广泛使用 GitHub Actions 来做我的很多开源东西，他们还没有向我收费，除非某个地方有某种不断增加的账单。对，是的。除非他们明天收到催收电话，我们走着瞧。是的，所以这就是伟大的地方。当你学习时，当你弄坏东西时不要沮丧。部分原因是看看你如何弄坏它。
I use GitHub Actions extensively for a lot of my open source stuff and they haven't charged me yet unless there's some mounting bill somewhere. Right, yeah. Unless they get a collections call tomorrow, we'll see. Yeah, so that's the great bill somewhere. Right, yeah. Unless they get a collections call tomorrow, we'll see. Yeah, so that's the great thing. When you're learning, don't be frustrated when you break things. Part of it is see how you can break it.
以不同的方式弄坏它，并学习那些坏掉的东西是如何解决的，以及你如何能弄清楚，改变方式来保持自动化运行，即使它遇到了不是关键的东西。关键也许它本意是，你知道，继续进行任何事情，这就是某种想法，不要，不要因为事情失败而沮丧，弄清楚它，并基本上把它作为一个学习机会。是的，绝对，是的，这是，这是很棒的，所以我认为，你知道，我们在节目中谈论的一个共同点，我们在这里双击的是，你知道，构建很酷的东西，这基本上是，你知道，简而言之。如果你构建很棒的东西，你将不得不维护它，我想这是 DevOps 的一件事，是，嗯，
Break it different ways and learn how those broken things are solved and how you can figure out, change ways to keep the automation going even if it hits something that's not critical. critical maybe it was meant to you know continue on with whatever and that's sort of the idea like don't don't get frustrated as things failing like figure it out and use that as a learning opportunity basically yeah definitely yeah this is uh this is great so i think you know one common thread that we've talked about on the show that we're just double clicking on here is is you know build cool stuff that's basically the the short of it if you build awesome stuff you're going to have to maintain it i guess that's one thing with with devops is uh um i guess you'll have to build
我想你将不得不为其他人构建东西，或者构建一些东西，你知道，你需要有一个流程，但即使你不这样做，我的意思是，你仍然会获得作为开发人员的绝佳经验，那将把你弹射到某个地方的 DevOps 职业生涯中。是的，绝对。酷。嘿，James，我知道你必须赶时间。非常感谢你花时间
something for other people or build something where where you know you need to have a process um but even if you don't i mean, you're still going to get a great experience as a developer and that will catapult you into a DevOps career somewhere. Yeah, absolutely. Cool. Hey, James, I know you have to rush. Thank you so much for taking the time
和我们交谈。我真的很感激。如果我从观众那里收到任何给你的问题，我会给你发电子邮件。是的，我总是需要你的帮助。很高兴来到这里，并感谢它的发生。酷。
to talk to us. I really appreciate it. And if I get any questions for you from the audience, I'll shoot you an email. Yeah, I always have your help. And it was great being here and appreciate it happening. Cool.
非常感谢。嘿，大家好。所以我们在这里参加 SwampUp，和 HelixML 的 CEO Luke Marsden 在一起。感谢你来到节目，Luke。很高兴来到这里。酷。那么，不如给人们简单介绍一下你是如何开始 Helix ML 的，以及你的背景故事是什么？是的，绝对。所以我是个创业者。我一生都在创业。这是第三家
Thanks a lot. Hey, everybody. So we are here at SwampUp with Luke Marsden, who's the CEO of HelixML. Thanks for coming on the show, Luke. It's great to be here. Cool. So why don't you give people a little bit of a background into how you kind of arrived into starting Helix ML and what's your kind of backstory? Yeah, absolutely. So I'm a startup guy. I've been doing startups my whole life. This is startup
创业公司。早在 15 岁时，我就创办了一家网络托管公司。哇。然后我去牛津大学攻读计算机科学。在那段经历之后，我真的很受启发，试图解决我们在网络托管公司遇到的一些实际问题。我通过构建一个分布式 Web 集群来做到这一点。然后这演变成了，我们最终将那项业务转型为解决 Docker 的存储问题，因为当
number three. Back when I was 15, I started a web hosting company. Wow. And I then went and did computer science at Oxford. And out of the back of that experience, I was really inspired to try and solve some of the practical problems we had in the web hosting company. And I did that by building a distributed web cluster. And then that evolved into, we ended up pivoting that business into solving storage for Docker because when
Docker 爆发时，我们就像，我们已经拥有了所有这些技术，用于处理有状态容器，因为我们当时在使用 FreeBSD Jails，所以我们只是将该技术应用于 Docker。好吧，让我们深入了解一下，所以我们有很多高中生在听，所以 15 岁创办一家公司，怎么做到的？那是怎么运作的？你怎么去对某人说，你知道，我会为你构建这个网站，你应该给我写一张支票。你的父母帮你了吗？或者你，你是怎么作为一个高中生做到这一点的？我的意思是，我有一个联合创始人，我是在 IRC 上在线认识的。那是我们过去在地面上交流的老派方式。
docker exploded we were like we already have all of this tech for um dealing with stateful containers because we were using freebsd jails and so we just applied that technology to um to docker well let's dive into a little bit so we have a lot of uh high school folks listening in so 15 years old start a company how. How does that work? How do you go to somebody and say, you know, I will build this website for you and you should write me a check. Did your parents help you with that? Or did you like, how do you do that as a high school student? I mean, I had a co-founder who I met online on IRC And that's like the old school way that we used to communicate back into the ground.
我过去很喜欢 IRC。它很棒。我的意思是，我想现在它会是 Discord，对吧？是的，完全正确。那是我们那个时代的 Discord。是的，完全正确。是的，我们只是决定一起创办一家网络托管公司。
I used to love IRC. It was great. I mean, I guess now it would be Discord, right? Yes, exactly. That was the Discord of our era. Yeah, exactly. And yeah, we just decided together to put together a web hosting company.
而关于那件事令人惊奇的是，我们只是能够把它放到网上，把网站放上去，并开始告诉人们关于它的事情。然后人们就出现了。发生了一件非常有趣的事情，对我们的业务帮助很大，我忘了它叫什么了，
And the amazing thing about that was that we were just able to put it online, put the website up there, and start telling people about it. And people showed up. And one really fun thing happened that helped us a lot with that business was, I've forgotten what it's called,
但有一个像这种基于 Perl 的旧博客框架。而创建那个博客框架的人发现了我们的网络托管服务。然后他离开了他的公司，然后他说，我对我的托管服务非常满意，在像他所有的观众面前。所以我们从那次中得到了很好的流量提升。那太棒了。
but there's like this old Perl-based blogging framework. And the guy who created that blogging framework found our web hosting service. And then he left his company and then he said, I'm really happy with my hosting service in front of like all of his audience. And so we got a nice boost in traffic from that. That's amazing.
是的，非常幸运。我不知道我是否在节目中说过这个，但我，我在高中时也做了很多事情，我构建的东西之一是一个小的等距游戏引擎，哦，是的，而且，当时没有很多游戏引擎，这是，这是，像 1997 年左右什么的，所以没有很多 Java，真的什么都没有。是的。所以它被一本书收录了，并且变得很受欢迎。我想知道，我想知道人们是否可以只是构建东西并让它们被注意到，或者那个时代是否已经过去了。我觉得现在你可能需要做一点更多的推广。
Yeah, it was very lucky. I don't know if I've ever told this on the show but but uh i did a lot in high school as well and one of the things i built was a little isometric game engine oh yeah and uh at the time there weren't a lot of game engines this was this was uh like 1997 or something and so there wasn't a lot of Java, really anything. Yeah. And so it got picked up in a book and it got popular. And I wonder if, I wonder if people can just build things and get them noticed or if that time has passed. I feel like now you probably need to do a little bit more promotion.
现在外面有太多的内容了。我的意思是，我，我认为那是真的，但，但，嗯，我认为如果你有解决问题的热情，那么，试一试，如果有什么的话，现在可能有更多传播信息的方式，我的意思是，我们当时没有 YouTube，我们没有，嗯，Discord 社区，我想这是真的，嗯，而且现在在线的人比当时多，所以是的，另一件事是，先锋已经移动了，换句话说，如果你想制作一个 Java 游戏引擎，我很抱歉，就像，有太多了，是的，但是，但是有一个 Hugging Face LLM 排行榜，是的，如果你，你知道，有各种各样的，
There's not, there's just so much content out there now. I mean, I, I think that's true, but true but um i think if you have a passion for solving a problem then um give it a go and if anything there's probably more ways of of getting the word out these days i mean we didn't have youtube back then like we didn't have um discord communities like i think it's true um uh and more people are online now than were then so yeah another thing is like there's the vanguard has moved so in other words if you want to make a java game engine i'm sorry like it's just there's too many of them yeah but but there's a hugging face uh llm leaderboard yes and if you you know there's a variety of them
所以你可能会带着一些热情和一些天赋，你可能会赢得希腊 LLM 排行榜。绝对。那么我应该继续我的故事吗？所以是的，我的意思是，我们做了
so you might end up with some passion and some talent, you might win the Greek LLM leaderboard Absolutely So shall I continue my story? So yeah, I mean we did the
存储，我们把那个业务混合集群转型为 ClusterHQ，它正在解决 Docker 的存储问题，然后我们参与了，嗯，在非常早期的 Docker 和 Kubernetes 时代，在人们真正知道如何让容器与像数据库和其他有状态服务一起工作之前。所以在那一点上，是的，我们筹集了 1500 万美元，仅仅是通过在 Sand Hill Road 上走来走去，并在同一个句子中说 Docker 和存储。那么，什么是 Sand Hill Road？
storage for, we pivoted that business hybrid cluster into Cluster hq which was solving um storage for docker and then we got involved um in the very early docker and kubernetes days back before um people really knew how to make um containers work with like databases and other stateful services. So at that point, yeah, we raised $15 million just by walking up and down Sand Hill Road and saying Docker and storage in the same sentence. Now, what is Sand Hill Road?
存储方面，我们将该业务混合集群转型为Cluster HQ，旨在解决Docker的存储问题。当时我们很早就参与了Docker和Kubernetes的早期开发，那时人们还不太清楚如何让容器与数据库及其他有状态服务协同工作。所以在那时，我们仅仅通过在沙山路（Sand Hill Road）走访，提到Docker和存储这两个词，就筹集到了1500万美元。那么，沙山路是什么呢？
Oh, so it's a road in Palo Alto where a lot of the VCs live or work. Yeah. So, yeah, there's a large concentration of venture capitalists. Very cool. I mean, was that intimidating? I mean, that sounds just like an extraordinary amount of money and responsibility. It was intimidating.
哦，那是帕洛阿托的一条路，很多风投都在那里居住或工作。是的。所以，那里聚集了大量的风险投资人。太酷了。我是说，那会让人感到畏惧吗？毕竟，那听起来涉及巨额的资金和责任。确实让人畏惧。
It was interesting. And I think I learned a lot from that experience. I think the biggest thing I learned was that even if you have a large Series A, you need to be really, really thoughtful about not growing the company too quickly before you really truly have product market fit. And so, yeah, that was one of the lessons learned. Like we grew the team quite quickly and it was challenging. But then beyond that first company. I then had another go. We had a... We built... We started out with
那很有趣。我想我从那次经历中学到了很多。我学到的最重要的一点是，即使你获得了大额的A轮融资，在真正实现产品与市场契合之前，你也需要非常、非常谨慎地避免公司扩张过快。所以，是的，这是我学到的教训之一。我们当时团队扩张得太快，这很有挑战性。但在那家公司之后，我又尝试了一次。我们……我们构建了……我们最初是从
this idea of versioning for development environments. Okay. So a lot of my career I've spent trying to find commercial applications of ZFS, which is a very clever bit of file system technology that came out of some microsystems and then got ported to Linux.
这个针对开发环境进行版本控制的想法开始的。好的。我的职业生涯中大部分时间都在尝试寻找 ZFS 的商业应用，这是一种非常巧妙的文件系统技术，源自 Sun Microsystems，后来被移植到了 Linux 上。
And so that attempt to commercializing ZFS was, well, if you've got a development environment and you manage to reproduce an interesting bug, let's say, on your laptop, then shouldn't you be able to not just do a git commit of the code at the point at which you can find the bug, but also take a snapshot of the local development databases that you have running, so that you could maybe attach a runnable snapshot of that thing to a GitHub issue, and then another developer could just pull it down and reproduce the bug immediately rather than having to click around in the UI to get the database into a certain state.
所以，那个商业化 ZFS 的尝试是这样的：如果你有一个开发环境，并且设法在笔记本电脑上重现了一个有趣的 Bug，那么你不仅应该能够在发现 Bug 的那个时间点对代码进行 git commit，还应该能够对正在运行的本地开发数据库进行快照，这样你就可以把那个可运行的快照附加到 GitHub 的 Issue 上，然后其他开发者就可以直接拉取并立即重现该 Bug，而不必在 UI 中点来点去地将数据库调整到特定状态。
Turns out that AI and machine learning had a much bigger data versioning problem than DevOps did and software engineering. And so we ended up pivoting to building out this end-to-end MLOps platform but with that same idea of
事实证明，人工智能和机器学习在数据版本控制方面的问题比 DevOps 和软件工程要大得多。因此，我们最终转型为构建这个端到端的 MLOps 平台，但核心理念依然是
versioning your workspace and so what data scientists like AI and ML people often do like when they're developing ideas is they use Jupyter notebooks but when you're using a Jupyter notebook it's very hard to keep track of your work very accurately and even like the order in which you run cells can affect the output and things like that. But what we did was to add this snapshotting of your state before and after you did a run. So if you did anything in the Jupyter notebook that would like train a model, for example, then we'd snapshot before and snapshot after. And then we'd also automatically build up this provenance graph so
对工作区进行版本控制。所以，AI 和 ML 从业者等数据科学家在开发想法时，经常使用 Jupyter Notebook，但当你使用 Jupyter Notebook 时，很难非常准确地跟踪你的工作，甚至你运行单元格的顺序都会影响输出结果等等。但我们所做的是在你运行前后添加了状态快照。所以，如果你在 Jupyter Notebook 中做了任何事情，比如训练模型，我们会在前后分别进行快照。然后我们还会自动构建这个溯源图，这样
you could say like oh i created this model from this data but this data was transformed from this other data using this process um and so you can kind of recursively build up this um uh this tree structure of how you got to that point um so yeah that that was uh that company was called dot science um and um yeah uh that was i love that name is it like the configs were in the dot science folder home directories how the name came it actually got really confusing because people would always put like a period and then science right but it was actually dot so it was oh that was a lesson in naming yeah department of transportation science yeah you can see other ways that that could get misconstrued yeah so a lot of people might not know this but zfs and btrfs yeah raw at fs they have this amazing property called copy
你就可以说，哦，我用这些数据创建了这个模型，但这些数据是通过这个过程从其他数据转换而来的。嗯，所以你可以递归地构建出这种树状结构，展示你是如何达到那个点的。嗯，是的，那家公司叫 Dot Science。嗯，是的，我喜欢那个名字。是因为配置都在 dot science 文件夹或主目录里吗？名字就是这么来的。其实这真的很让人困惑，因为人们总是会写成一个点然后是 science，但实际上是 dot，所以……哦，那是一个关于命名的教训。是的，交通运输科学部。你可以看出这在其他方面可能会被误解。是的，所以很多人可能不知道这一点，但 ZFS 和 Btrfs，是的，Raw at fs，它们有一个惊人的特性叫写时复制（copy-on-write）。
on right and the way it works is uh you've probably done this even for school projects and you might say like i have a document um i mean nowadays probably everything's in the cloud so it's kind of transparent but you might say like i have i have a set of artwork um that i'm working on some digital art and uh you know i'm iterating on it but i don't want to lose my history and it doesn't really make sense to create a Git repository. I might not know how to do that. The simplest thing would be just create a folder for each day and just have my Blender files or my Photoshop files
它的工作原理是……你可能在学校项目中也做过类似的事情，你可能会说，我有一个文档……我是说现在可能一切都在云端，所以这很透明，但你可能会说，我有一套我正在创作的数字艺术作品，你知道，我正在迭代它，但我不想丢失我的历史记录，而且创建一个 Git 仓库也没什么意义。我可能不知道怎么做。最简单的方法就是为每一天创建一个文件夹，然后把我的 Blender 文件或 Photoshop 文件
just copied in each folder. And then that starts to become really expensive because you might have all these other assets and they're just all getting copied every single day end up using up all your disk space do that exactly zfs is has a genius idea it's basically reference counting so when you copy a file zfs doesn't actually copy it it just creates a shared pointer between those two files. Now, as soon as you change even one bit of that, of either of those files, then ZFS has to make a copy. But if you don't do that, you can have 100, 1,000, 1,000 copies of the file, and it's not going to increase your storage costs linearly like
复制到每个文件夹里。然后这开始变得非常昂贵，因为你可能有所有这些其他资产，它们每天都在被复制，最终会耗尽你所有的磁盘空间。完全正确。ZFS 有一个天才的想法，它基本上是引用计数，所以当你复制一个文件时，ZFS 并没有真正复制它，它只是在两个文件之间创建了一个共享指针。现在，一旦你改变了其中任何一个文件的哪怕一个比特，ZFS 就必须进行复制。但如果你不这样做，你可以有 100 个、1000 个、10000 个文件副本，它不会像
a regular file system. And so I've always been fascinated by that. I really was intent to install BitRotFS on my latest computer that I got about a week ago, but it wasn't supported by Grub or some other issues. And so it's to your point, like it's still not totally smooth yet. And it's been around for a long time, unfortunately. Yeah, well, I mean, Ubuntu embraced ZFS on Linux, you know smooth yet yeah it's been around for a long time unfortunately yeah well i mean ubuntu uh embraced zfs on linux fortunately and so you can install ubuntu with a zfs root um right so um
普通文件系统那样线性增加你的存储成本。所以我一直对这一点很着迷。我本来打算在我大约一周前买的最新电脑上安装 Btrfs，但它不支持 Grub 或存在其他一些问题。所以正如你所说，它仍然不够完美。不幸的是，它已经存在很长时间了。是的，我是说，Ubuntu 在 Linux 上采用了 ZFS，你知道……不够完美，是的，它已经存在很长时间了，不幸的是。是的，我是说，Ubuntu 幸运地在 Linux 上采用了 ZFS，所以你可以安装带有 ZFS 根分区的 Ubuntu，对吧？所以……
yeah i mean i encourage anyone who's brave enough to give that a go and you can do all these cool things but i mean we run like uh my newest company, HelixML, we run all of the infrastructure for that in a data center in my basement. Really? Yeah, because we're bootstrapping the business. So we didn't want to incur a ton of cloud costs. So I mean, it's not got a fiber link. And yeah, we use ZFS on Linux for all of the production storage for that and then actually rsync.net this is an interesting piece of ZFS trivia rsync.net has support for they're a backup provider but they have support for like ZFS send into rsync.net and then they provide that as a service so what that does is it means that you can take a snapshot every day of your production system
是的，我是说，我鼓励任何有勇气的人去尝试一下，你可以做所有这些很酷的事情。但我是说，我们运行……比如我的最新公司 HelixML，我们所有的基础设施都运行在我地下室的数据中心里。真的吗？是的，因为我们是在白手起家（bootstrapping）。所以我们不想承担巨额的云成本。所以，我是说，它没有光纤链路。是的，我们所有的生产存储都使用 Linux 上的 ZFS，实际上还有 rsync.net。这是一个有趣的 ZFS 冷知识，rsync.net 支持……他们是一个备份提供商，但他们支持像 ZFS send 到 rsync.net，然后他们将其作为一项服务提供。所以它的作用是，这意味着你可以每天对你的生产系统进行快照，
and it's an atomic, reliable snapshot that doesn't take up any extra disk space like you were saying. And then you can just send the difference between that snapshot and the previous day's snapshot over to rsync.net and it will automatically keep up to date. Anyway, we've ended up falling down a
这是一个原子的、可靠的快照，不会像你刚才说的那样占用任何额外的磁盘空间。然后你只需要把那个快照和前一天快照之间的差异发送到 rsync.net，它就会自动保持更新。总之，我们最终掉进了
file system rabbit hole no that's fine okay one last file system question because it's just burning in my mind what is the difference and feel free to just cut me off so you can take a rabbit hole turn but what's the difference between zfs and bitrot fs are they totally different things or are they two people trying to do the same thing well i like how you describe it as Bitch Rot FS. I think that's what it is, right? Or no? I think that's a joke.
文件系统的兔子洞里了。不，没关系。好的，最后一个关于文件系统的问题，因为它一直在困扰我。ZFS 和 Btrfs 之间有什么区别？它们是完全不同的东西，还是两个人试图做同样的事情？嗯，我喜欢你把它描述成 Bitch Rot FS。我想这就是它的名字，对吧？或者不是？我想那是个笑话。
Oh, really? I thought that was the official... I think it's called Butter FS. Oh, you are totally calling it... But I think you fell for it. You know, I have to admit, I've said this on Show Local Times, I am known to be the most gullible person.
哦，真的吗？我以为那是官方的……我想它叫 Butter FS。哦，你完全是在叫它……但我认为你上当了。你知道，我必须承认，我在 Show Local Times 上说过，我以最容易上当受骗的人而闻名。
You know, different people have their superhero strengths and weaknesses. Like I fall for everything all the time. So I'm not surprised. Well, no, I mean, I don't mean it in a negative way. I just think it's, I can imagine someone on the internet calling it bitch rot FS as a joke because it's like bitch rot. It's actually, I looked it up.
你知道，不同的人有不同的超级英雄般的长处和弱点。比如我总是上当受骗。所以我并不感到惊讶。好吧，不，我的意思不是负面的。我只是觉得，我可以想象互联网上有人把它戏称为 Bitch Rot FS，因为它听起来像 bitch rot。实际上，我查过了。
It's better FS. Yes. That is the official name. Or BtreeFS, which probably makes the most sense, right? Yeah. Well, I think BitrotFS is actually quite apt because it's, yeah, I mean, that project has been plagued with data loss issues and I've never really trusted it to actually be reliable.
它是 Btrfs。是的。那是官方名称。或者 BtreeFS，这可能最有意义，对吧？是的。嗯，我觉得 BitrotFS 其实很贴切，因为它……是的，我是说，那个项目一直受到数据丢失问题的困扰，我从来没有真正信任过它能真正可靠。
Whereas ZFS was engineered at some microsystems like very nicely. Interesting. And I was grateful when I stopped having to run Solaris to use it. Because it got ported to FreeBSD and this is like back in the day when we were doing this web hosting company.
而 ZFS 是在 Sun Microsystems 设计的，非常出色。有趣。当我不再需要运行 Solaris 来使用它时，我很感激。因为它被移植到了 FreeBSD，这还是我们做网络托管公司的时候。
But yeah, anyway. Well, that is fascinating. There were licensing issues, right? But I guess it's all cleared up. Yes. And I think the, yeah, I'm glad that Mark Shuttleworth at Canonical kind of took a stand on that.
但无论如何。嗯，这太迷人了。当时有许可问题，对吧？但我猜现在都解决了。是的。而且我认为，是的，我很高兴 Canonical 的 Mark Shuttleworth 在这方面采取了立场。
And he said like, we're going to go ahead with this. Our lawyers have cleared it. And that like really cleared the way for a stand on that. And he said, like, we're going to go ahead with this. Our lawyers have cleared it. That really cleared the way for a lot of other people to say, like, okay, if it's good enough for Ubuntu, then we can use it. Nice. That is great. That is Ubuntu's real big contribution is just getting everybody to have faith
他说，我们要继续这样做。我们的律师已经清理了障碍。这确实为……他说，我们要继续这样做。我们的律师已经清理了障碍。这确实为其他许多人扫清了道路，让他们觉得，好吧，如果它对 Ubuntu 来说足够好，那么我们也可以使用它。不错。那太棒了。那是 Ubuntu 真正的巨大贡献，就是让每个人都对
in the whole ecosystem. So, okay, we talked in previous episodes about DevOps. We had a dedicated show about it. We've interviewed some folks about DevOps. For folks who are listening, if you missed the DevOps episode, hit the pause button on this episode. Go back, listen to the DevOps episode because what we're going to talk about now
整个生态系统充满信心。所以，好的，我们在之前的剧集中讨论过 DevOps。我们有一个专门的节目讨论它。我们采访了一些关于 DevOps 的人。对于正在收听的朋友，如果你错过了 DevOps 那一集，请按下暂停键，回去听听 DevOps 那一集，因为我们现在要讨论的是
is the delta between DevOps and MLOps. MLOps is much newer. You know, we haven't spent a whole bunch of time on it on the show. But as folks know, AI is becoming, you know, really, really important. And so MLOps itself is also becoming, you know, important by proxy. So what is MLOps and how does it differ from DevOps? So if you think of three disciplines, software engineering, just like how you write and develop software, how you test it, how you version it,
DevOps 和 MLOps 之间的差异。MLOps 要新得多。你知道，我们在节目中还没有花太多时间讨论它。但正如大家所知，AI 正在变得非常、非常重要。因此，MLOps 本身也通过代理变得重要起来。那么什么是 MLOps，它与 DevOps 有何不同？如果你想到三个学科：软件工程，就像你如何编写和开发软件，如何测试它，如何对其进行版本控制，
and you think about DevOps, which is how you do CICD for deployment, how you operate that, how you do CICD for deployment, how you operate that, how you do immutable infrastructure in the cloud and things like that. And then you layer in this third discipline, which is AI ML, which is like this world of using data to generate models that pull the patterns out of that data and are able to make predictions, right? ML Ops is the intersection of those three disciplines.
然后你想到 DevOps，也就是你如何进行 CICD 部署，如何操作它，如何进行 CICD 部署，如何操作它，如何在云中进行不可变基础设施等等。然后你加入这第三个学科，即 AI ML，也就是利用数据生成模型，从数据中提取模式并能够进行预测的世界，对吧？MLOps 就是这三个学科的交叉点。
So it's the intersection of software, DevOps, and AI ML. That makes sense. And so if somebody wants to get started in the field of MLOps, how do they not get uh overwhelmed with all three because all three of those are you could spend a lifetime they're all crafts of their own i think data science and and data engineering is a craft software engineering is a craft you know ai and you know making the loss go down it's a craft craft I've spent many, many years on. So how do people get in that intersection?
所以它是软件、DevOps 和 AI ML 的交叉点。这很有道理。所以如果有人想进入 MLOps 领域，他们如何才能不被这三个领域压垮呢？因为这三个领域中的任何一个你都可以花一辈子去钻研，它们都是各自的工艺。我认为数据科学和数据工程是一门工艺，软件工程是一门工艺，你知道 AI，你知道让损失函数下降，这是一门我花了很多很多年钻研的工艺。那么人们如何进入这个交叉点呢？
Is it the kind of job where it's really more of a mid-senior level or can folks kind of get into that and what would that look like? I would say that in order to become an MLOps practitioner, you only need a little bit of all three. So for example, if on the software side, you learn a bit of Python and you're comfortable with Git, on the DevOps side, you get comfortable with Docker and containerizing things and maybe deploying Docker Compose, maybe push out into Kubernetes. And although I'd say Kubernetes is optional. And then on the AIML side,
这是那种真正属于中高级水平的工作吗？还是人们可以进入这个领域？那会是什么样子？我会说，为了成为一名 MLOps 从业者，你只需要对这三个领域都有一点了解。例如，在软件方面，你学习一点 Python，并且熟悉 Git；在 DevOps 方面，你熟悉 Docker 和容器化，也许部署 Docker Compose，也许推送到 Kubernetes。虽然我会说 Kubernetes 是可选的。然后在 AI ML 方面，
if you just like train a linear regression model or something in PyTorch or like XGBoost, I mean, that's enough to get you started. And then you can start looking at tools like MLflow, which allow you to keep track of model artifacts and track runs. That was something we were big on in my second company, DotScience, was this idea of run tracking.
如果你只是训练一个线性回归模型，或者在 PyTorch 或 XGBoost 中做点什么，我是说，这就足以让你入门了。然后你可以开始查看像 MLflow 这样的工具，它们允许你跟踪模型工件和运行记录。这是我在我的第二家公司 DotScience 时非常看重的一点，就是这种运行跟踪的想法。
And yeah, deploy one of these models into production using Git, Docker, PyTorch or whatever, and now you're an MLOps engineer. And then you can take it from there and there's lots more sophistication and how you scale the systems and so on. But basically, that's what you need. So it might sound intimidating
是的，使用 Git、Docker、PyTorch 或其他任何工具将这些模型之一部署到生产环境中，现在你就是一名 MLOps 工程师了。然后你可以从那里开始，还有很多关于如何扩展系统等的复杂性。但基本上，这就是你所需要的。所以这听起来可能很吓人，
because it's like three different disciplines. But yeah, if you just take a little bit of each one um then you can get up and running and i would uh shout out to the mlops community um so mlops.community uh is actually a community that we started at the end of dot science um actually like right when the pandemic started uh our sales pipeline dried up and we were like what are we going to do so going to do? So let's start an open community around MLOps. It's like, I'd always wanted to do that. We bootstrapped that community from nothing with another tech community called BrizTech in Bristol, where I live in England.
因为它就像三个不同的学科。但是的，如果你只是从每个学科中取一点点，那么你就可以上手了。而且我会向 MLOps 社区致敬，所以 mlops.community 其实是我们是在 Dot Science 末期开始的一个社区，实际上就在疫情刚开始的时候，我们的销售渠道枯竭了，我们当时想，我们要怎么办？所以，让我们围绕 MLOps 建立一个开放社区。就像，我一直想这样做。我们和英国布里斯托尔的另一个名为 BrizTech 的技术社区一起，从零开始建立了那个社区。
And then my colleague Dimitrios took the MLOps community and ran with it. And we're now like over 20,000 people on Slack. Wow. We've got a meetup in San Francisco this Thursday, which we're hosting. And there's meetups all over the planet. So it's amazing how these things can evolve. Wow, that is remarkable. But there's tons of really great material on MLOps, on the MLOps community.
然后我的同事 Dimitrios 接手了 MLOps 社区并将其发扬光大。我们现在 Slack 上有超过 20,000 人。哇。我们本周四在旧金山有一个聚会，我们正在主办。而且全世界各地都有聚会。所以这些事情的发展方式真是令人惊叹。哇，这太了不起了。但在 MLOps 社区上，有大量非常棒的 MLOps 资料。
There's a good YouTube. And yeah, I'd recommend that as a resource yeah that is great i love how like you took such a kinesthetic approach to it i i'm right on the same page i think uh um i'll read the book when you know i've kind of uh have something half built and it doesn't work and it's like okay now it's time to read the manual i know some people are the opposite i used to report to my manager used to be uh peter norvig at google and he would he would read the book first so it's like oh we're going to use python okay i'm going to just start reading the python manual from page one yeah my wife is like that yeah yeah i mean but uh i think that uh for me like what works is starting with some kind of problem and what i've learned over time is actually even better than that and i'm this is
有一个很好的 YouTube 频道。是的，我会推荐它作为资源。是的，那太棒了。我喜欢你采取这种动觉学习法的方式。我完全同意。我想……我会读那本书，当我知道我已经构建了一半的东西，但它不起作用时，我会想，好吧，现在是阅读手册的时候了。我知道有些人正好相反。我以前向我的经理汇报，他曾经是谷歌的 Peter Norvig，他会先读那本书，所以他会说，哦，我们要用 Python，好的，我要从第一页开始阅读 Python 手册。是的，我妻子就是那样。是的，是的，但我认为对我来说，有效的方法是从某种问题开始。随着时间的推移，我学到的是，实际上比那更好的是……我在这里
where i'm not um there yet but i'm trying is actually starting with a customer yes you know i think uh starting with uh you know a person who has a problem but you know before that I think using yourself and saying okay what is a problem
还没有达到那个水平，但我正在尝试……实际上是从客户开始。是的，你知道，我认为从一个有问题的客户开始……但在那之前，我认为利用你自己，说，好吧，什么是问题？
in the real world for me starting with that and working backwards to you know what AI thing do I need to build and then
在现实世界中，对我来说，从那个问题开始，然后反向推导，你知道我需要构建什么 AI 东西，然后
what language do I need to build the AI thing and go from there well if I may tell the story of the most recent company like Helix amount
我需要什么语言来构建那个 AI 东西，然后从那里开始。好吧，如果我可以讲讲最近那家公司 HelixML 的故事的话。
yeah definitely dive into that so like um uh yeah after dot science i did consulting for a few years um and worked with clients all over the world which was great i really recommend it actually like being a one man or one person consulting company can be really amazing. But then what happened, I was watching this kind of open source AI space kind of towards the middle to end of last year, like August, September, 2023. And I saw these two really interesting things happening. The first one was that MrL7B came out. And now suddenly, suddenly you could have a good quality LLM,
是的，一定要深入讲讲那个。所以，嗯，在 Dot Science 之后，我做了几年的咨询工作，与世界各地的客户合作，这很棒。我其实很推荐它，作为一个单人咨询公司真的可以非常棒。但后来发生的事情是，我一直在观察这个开源 AI 空间，大概在去年年中到年底，比如 2023 年 8 月、9 月。我看到了两件非常有趣的事情正在发生。第一件事是 Mistral 7B 发布了。现在突然之间，你就可以拥有一个高质量的 LLM，
like a chat GPT level-ish LLM that you could run locally on your own machine. And the other piece was that it became possible to both run but also fine-tune those models on consumer hardware. So you could now have an almost chat gpt level um model that you could fine-tune on your own private data on like a single 3090 like the kind of gaming um gpu that you might have in your in your home pc now like let's dive into that a little bit for folks so you know a lot of people have heard the word fine-tuning yeah but like how do people actually
一个 ChatGPT 级别左右的 LLM，你可以在自己的机器上本地运行。另一部分是，不仅可以运行，而且可以在消费级硬件上微调这些模型。所以你现在可以拥有一个几乎 ChatGPT 级别的模型，你可以在自己的私有数据上进行微调，比如在一块 3090 上，就像你家里电脑里可能有的那种游戏 GPU。现在，让我们为听众深入探讨一下这一点。你知道，很多人都听说过“微调”这个词，但人们实际上是如何
do that here's i'll say what i think it is and you can correct me and fill in the gaps so when they trained mistral they had some pytorch or tensorflow or mx net whatever it is they had some code to train mistral they give people that code and so you can basically run that code on the current model and basically continue training on your own data is that is that pretty much how it works exactly so fine tuning is just more training okay um so you take the weights of an existing model um and you train it more on training data that is your own private training data um it is a little bit more complicated than that because there's a technique that's often used called low rank adaptation, which I don't fully understand the math, but
做到的呢？我会说出我认为它是怎么回事，你可以纠正我并填补空白。所以当他们训练 Mistral 时，他们有一些 PyTorch 或 TensorFlow 或 MXNet，无论是什么，他们有一些代码来训练 Mistral。他们把代码给人们，所以你基本上可以在当前模型上运行该代码，并基本上在自己的数据上继续训练。这基本上就是它的工作原理吗？完全正确。所以微调就是更多的训练。好的。所以你获取现有模型的权重，并在你自己的私有训练数据上进行更多的训练。这比这稍微复杂一点，因为有一种经常使用的技术叫低秩适应（Low-Rank Adaptation，LoRA），我不完全理解其中的数学原理，但
it's some sort of matrix decomposition where you end up just having to train like a much smaller set of weights than the whole set of weights. And that's really cool because it makes it tractable to train or to do more training on this model but without needing huge memory requirements. And that's what I mean by it became possible to fine-tune Mistral yourself on a single GPU. And that
它是一种矩阵分解，你最终只需要训练比整套权重小得多的权重集。这真的很酷，因为它使得在模型上进行训练或进行更多训练变得可行，而不需要巨大的内存需求。这就是我所说的，在单块 GPU 上微调 Mistral 变得可行了。而这
depends on that kind of lower... So is it holding the original model in the CPU memory and then the GPU memory has the low-rank version? That's a really good question. I mean, I think everything fits in GPU memory, but I think it only needs to do backpropagation on the smaller matrix.
取决于那种较低的……所以它是把原始模型保存在 CPU 内存中，然后 GPU 内存中有低秩版本吗？这是一个非常好的问题。我是说，我认为一切都适合 GPU 内存，但我认为它只需要在较小的矩阵上进行反向传播。
Oh, that makes sense. Yeah, so it's able to do that with fewer resources and it also just takes less time. Right, that makes sense yeah because for folks who don't know the um the way the way back propagation works and we talked about this a little bit in the ai episodes but you keep this gradient matrix so effectively doubles the amount of memory you need because for every matrix you need this sort of shadow right yeah and if and you might need to up the resolution
哦，那说得通。是的，所以它能够用更少的资源做到这一点，而且也花费更少的时间。对，那说得通。是的，因为对于不知道反向传播工作原理的听众来说，我们在 AI 剧集中讨论过一点，但你保留了这个梯度矩阵，所以实际上使你需要的内存量翻倍了，因为对于每个矩阵，你需要这种影子……对，是的。而且你可能需要提高分辨率，
too like maybe the model can run an 8-bit but for training it has to be 16-bit and so so that now you're talking about a 4x multiplier and so if you can just do inference on the big model it can sit in 8-bit yeah and then do the training on the smaller 32-bit or 16-bit model. That is really cool. Yeah, so I noticed these two really interesting things happening in the world. And I turned to my friend and co-founder Kai in Bristol and I said, it's time to have another go. So was he with you at Dark Science?
比如模型可以在 8 位下运行，但训练时必须是 16 位，所以现在你谈论的是 4 倍的乘数。所以如果你只是在大型模型上进行推理，它可以以 8 位运行，然后在较小的 32 位或 16 位模型上进行训练。这真的很酷。是的，所以我注意到世界上正在发生这两件非常有趣的事情。我转向我在布里斯托尔的朋友兼联合创始人 Kai 说，是时候再试一次了。所以他在 Dot Science 时和你在一起吗？
Yeah, we kind of got the band back together. So for helix um yeah we um we saw this this opportunity and we went in and we we then like spent two three months furiously hacking together the stack i mean that we we joked that it took us 10 years to know what to build in 10 days yeah that's how it goes it goes. But yeah, we put together this stack that allowed you to deploy these open source models like Mistral 7b and also fine tune them. And to make that easy for people with like a nice web interface where you just drag and drop in some PDFs or some documents. And then we did this interesting piece around the fine-tuning where we would take the source documents, chunk them down into little pieces, and then we would use an LLM to generate training data from those source documents.
是的，我们算是重新聚在一起了。所以对于 Helix，是的，我们看到了这个机会，我们进去了，然后我们花了两个月时间疯狂地拼凑这个技术栈。我是说，我们开玩笑说，我们花了 10 年时间才知道在 10 天内构建什么。是的，事情就是这样。但是的，我们拼凑了这个技术栈，让你能够部署这些开源模型，比如 Mistral 7B，也可以微调它们。为了让人们通过一个漂亮的网页界面轻松做到这一点，你只需拖放一些 PDF 或文档。然后我们在微调方面做了一个有趣的尝试，我们会获取源文档，将它们切分成小块，然后我们会使用一个 LLM 从这些源文档中生成训练数据。
Because what you want to do when you're fine-tuning is train on data that's similar to the kind of questions that a user would ask of it, assuming it's an instruct style model, like a question answering model. So you can't just train it on the raw text because then it will just be good at completing the raw text. But what you need is you need to train it on things that are like the questions that users are going to ask. So we actually use another LLM
因为当你进行微调时，你想做的是在与用户可能问的问题相似的数据上进行训练，假设它是一个指令风格的模型，比如问答模型。所以你不能只在原始文本上训练它，因为那样它只会擅长补全原始文本。但你需要的是在用户将要问的问题上进行训练。所以我们实际上使用另一个 LLM
to transform the source documents into questions and answers about the source documents. And then we use those question answer pairs to fine tune the model. Our most popular blog post was how we got fine tuning Mistral 7b to not suck. And that goes into a bit more detail. So maybe this is a dumb question, but these models are known to be trained on enormous data sets. And I think there's one called the pile. It's like 10 terabytes of text or something. Some enormous amount.
将源文档转换为关于源文档的问题和答案。然后我们使用这些问答对来微调模型。我们最受欢迎的博客文章是“我们是如何让 Mistral 7B 的微调不那么糟糕的”。那篇文章讲得更详细。所以这可能是一个愚蠢的问题，但这些模型已知是在庞大的数据集上训练的。我想有一个叫 The Pile 的数据集。它有 10TB 的文本还是什么的。非常巨大的量。
How does your fine tuning have any statistical significance when you compare it to just this enormous data set? Like how are you able to, to move the model, move the needle right on the model? Yeah, so I think it has to do with like, the learning rate that you choose, when you're doing the fine tuning. And what, what has been found kind of empirically is that even just using a very small number of samples in fine tuning with like, I guess, a relatively high learning rate. So it makes them makes the model change quite a lot, but not too much. Because if you go too far, then it just goes like
当你把它与这个巨大的数据集相比时，你的微调怎么会有任何统计学意义呢？你是如何能够移动模型，在模型上产生影响的？是的，所以我认为这与你在进行微调时选择的学习率有关。经验上发现，即使在微调中只使用极少量的样本，并配合相对较高的学习率。所以它使模型产生相当大的变化，但又不会太多。因为如果你走得太远，它就会
haywire and starts spouting garbage. So you've got to find this like middle ground. But even with a small number of samples, you can get the model to start generating things that are similar to the fine-tuning dataset or start generating responses in a different style or with a different structure really quite quickly. And then it's about finding that trade-off. You don't want to over-bake the thing so that it just kind of memorizes that and forgets all of its prior learning from from uh from the pre-training um makes sense but
失控并开始胡言乱语。所以你必须找到这种中间地带。但即使样本量很少，你也可以让模型开始生成与微调数据集相似的内容，或者开始以不同的风格或不同的结构生成响应，而且速度非常快。然后关键在于找到那个权衡。你不想把东西烤得太焦，以至于它只是记住了那些东西，而忘记了它从预训练中学到的所有先验知识……说得通，但
yeah we we like tuned those parameters and we found something that worked um but then the interesting thing was i guess commercially from a business perspective is that we went into the market in december last year um with two hypotheses the first hypothesis was um let's uh people will care about running models on their own infrastructure. People will care about local LLMs. And the second hypothesis was, people will care about fine-tuning, and in particular, fine-tuning for knowledge, which was that piece that we developed. And what we heard back from the market was a resounding yes to running models locally so we launched on december 21 um uh on december 24 uh this company shows up on our discord and they're like we're based in
是的，我们调整了那些参数，我们找到了一些有效的方法。但有趣的是，从商业角度来看，我们在去年 12 月进入市场时有两个假设。第一个假设是，人们会关心在自己的基础设施上运行模型。人们会关心本地 LLM。第二个假设是，人们会关心微调，特别是针对知识的微调，也就是我们开发的那个部分。而我们从市场得到的反馈是对在本地运行模型的一致好评。所以我们在 12 月 21 日发布，12 月 24 日，这家公司出现在我们的 Discord 上，他们说我们总部在
germany we're really interested in self-hosting these models we're not ml experts but we see the opportunity and by january 1 they'd integrated Helix already into their stack. Wow, this is incredible. And then they were going after big enterprise customers in partnership with us. And so that was really exciting. It's like the universe was telling us there is an appetite for running LLMs locally and building the capabilities to make that easy to do.
德国，我们对自托管这些模型非常感兴趣。我们不是 ML 专家，但我们看到了机会。到 1 月 1 日，他们已经将 Helix 集成到了他们的技术栈中。哇，这太不可思议了。然后他们与我们合作，去争取大型企业客户。所以这非常令人兴奋。就像宇宙在告诉我们，人们对在本地运行 LLM 并构建使其易于实现的能力有需求。
Now, in terms of the second or the first, well, the second hypothesis about fine tuning, we actually got a big meh from the market. Like we put all this effort into fine tuning stuff. Everyone just said like, oh, we just want to do RAG, like retrieval augmented generation. Yeah, interesting. Why do you think that is in hindsight? I think because fine-tuning for knowledge is slower than RAG, and the results are not as good.
现在，关于第二个，或者第一个……好吧，关于微调的第二个假设，我们实际上从市场得到了一个巨大的“meh”（无感）。就像我们投入了所有这些精力去微调东西。每个人都只是说，哦，我们只想做 RAG，也就是检索增强生成。是的，有趣。事后看来，你认为为什么会这样？我认为是因为针对知识的微调比 RAG 慢，而且结果也不如 RAG 好。
So it was kind of an experiment to see, oh, well, maybe people will care about it. But yeah, I mean, and so what we did was we extended the stack. So we added RAG to it. And the other thing we did was we added API calling, which is where you can give the model an open API, which is confusing because it's not open AI, it's open API spec.
所以这算是一个实验，看看人们是否会关心它。但是的，我们所做的是扩展了技术栈。所以我们向其中添加了 RAG。我们做的另一件事是添加了 API 调用，你可以给模型一个 Open API，这很令人困惑，因为它不是 OpenAI，而是 Open API 规范。
It used to be called Swagger. A Swagger spec. It's easier to just describe it as a Swagger spec. So you give the model a Swagger spec, and then you give it a query from the user, and you basically say, a bit like how function calling works, you say to the model,
它以前叫 Swagger。Swagger 规范。直接把它描述为 Swagger 规范更容易。所以你给模型一个 Swagger 规范，然后你给它一个用户的查询，你基本上说，有点像函数调用的工作方式，你对模型说，
you've got these three APIs you can call, and please class... So it comes in three parts, the API calling. The first part is classify the user's question and then tell you whether the user's query requires an API call. Yes or no, and if so, which one? And then the second step is constructing the API call. So assuming that you want to make an API call based on the user's question, like, can I rent a crane that can handle three tons in Hamburg next Thursday,
你有这三个 API 可以调用，请分类……所以 API 调用分为三个部分。第一部分是分类用户的问题，然后告诉你用户的查询是否需要 API 调用。是还是否，如果是，是哪一个？然后第二步是构建 API 调用。所以假设你想根据用户的问题进行 API 调用，比如，“我能在下周四在汉堡租到一台能处理三吨重的起重机吗？”
like construct an API call that will query the product catalog with the correct question. And then the third part is taking the response from the API. So the system will execute the API call for you. And then taking the response from that API and summarizing it back to the user. So from the user's perspective, they're just saying, like, hey, have you got a crane? And the model quickly says, yes, I've got one. I've got these three available. They cost this much.
构建一个 API 调用，用正确的问题查询产品目录。然后第三部分是获取 API 的响应。所以系统会为你执行 API 调用。然后获取该 API 的响应并将其总结回给用户。所以从用户的角度来看，他们只是说，“嘿，你有起重机吗？”模型很快回答，“是的，我有。我有这三台可供选择。它们价格是多少。”
But what's actually happening underneath is that classification, API call construction, and summarization steps. Interesting. So that API calling feature has been really commercially successful for us and tons of people are interested in that. And so I'll just shout out quickly to the fact that we did our 1.0 launch
但底层实际发生的是分类、API 调用构建和总结步骤。有趣。所以那个 API 调用功能对我们来说在商业上非常成功，很多人对此感兴趣。所以我要快速提一下，我们上周进行了 1.0 版本发布。
last week. So yeah, if you're interested in running models locally, we now run on Windows, Mac, and Linux. You can run it alongside Ollama. We have a nice application editor, so you can click buttons to set these things up and add knowledge with RAG,
所以如果你对在本地运行模型感兴趣，我们现在可以在 Windows、Mac 和 Linux 上运行。你可以和 Ollama 一起运行它。我们有一个很好的应用程序编辑器，所以你可以点击按钮来设置这些东西，并通过 RAG 添加知识，
add API integrations, and so on. So if people don't have, let's say, a GPU, could they still run Helix on, let's say, an EC2 instance? Yes, and you can even just run it on CPU because Olamo runs on CPU as well. Oh, okay. Got it. However, if you have a Mac, like one of the more recent M1, M2, M3 Macs,
添加 API 集成等等。所以如果人们没有 GPU，他们还能在 EC2 实例上运行 Helix 吗？是的，你甚至可以在 CPU 上运行它，因为 Ollama 也在 CPU 上运行。哦，好的。明白了。但是，如果你有一台 Mac，比如较新的 M1、M2、M3 Mac，
Olamo also works with the GPUs on those machines. So you actually get really quite good performance on a Mac. On a CPU Linux or Windows machine, it will be a bit slower. But if you've got like a gaming rig at home running Windows, then you can install WSL2, like Windows subsystem for Linux and Docker, and then the whole thing does work. Yeah, it's pretty cool. That is awesome. So yeah. Or you can dual boot and have a Linux machine with ZFS on it. Yes. That is another option. That's really cool. So how does that work?
Ollama 也可以使用这些机器上的 GPU。所以你在 Mac 上实际上可以获得相当不错的性能。在 CPU Linux 或 Windows 机器上，它会慢一点。但如果你家里有一台运行 Windows 的游戏机，那么你可以安装 WSL2，即 Windows Linux 子系统和 Docker，然后整个东西就能运行了。是的，这很酷。那太棒了。所以是的。或者你可以双启动，拥有一台带有 ZFS 的 Linux 机器。是的。那是另一个选择。这真的很酷。那么它是如何工作的？
It's like a desktop or a library. I guess I'm trying to figure out. So in the case of OpenAI, they give you a key and you're calling into their server with their key and that's how they do billing and all of that. In your case, how does that work? Is it, I guess, also a key, but you run, you get the key from from helix.ml i so we are docker desktop license so like if you have less than 10 million dollars of annual revenue then you can use us for free oh perfect just download
它是一个桌面程序还是一个库？我试图弄清楚。在 OpenAI 的情况下，他们给你一个密钥，你用他们的密钥调用他们的服务器，这就是他们进行计费和所有这些的方式。在你的情况下，它是如何工作的？我猜也是一个密钥，但你运行它，你从 helix.ml 获取密钥。我是说，我们是 Docker Desktop 许可的，所以如果你每年的收入少于 1000 万美元，那么你可以免费使用我们。哦，太完美了。只需在网站上下载
it on the website like and uh it's um it's an install script so you just like run our installer that creates a Docker Compose file you run Docker Compose up and then you look at localhost in the browser and the whole thing is running there but that means of course you can then also deploy that if you're a company you can deploy that on your own internal infrastructure
它，它是一个安装脚本，所以你只需运行我们的安装程序，它会创建一个 Docker Compose 文件，你运行 Docker Compose up，然后在浏览器中查看 localhost，整个东西就在那里运行了。但这当然意味着如果你是一家公司，你也可以将其部署在你自己的内部基础设施上。
and that's where the DevOps piece comes in we also support Kubernetes so you can run the whole stack on Kubernetes and yeah we use Kubernetes We also support Kubernetes, so you can run the whole stack on Kubernetes. And yeah, we might use Kubernetes with a bunch of GPUs in production for our own service. Very cool. Yeah, this is fascinating. Okay, so maybe we'll wrap up with like, what's one last piece of advice for, let's say someone's listening right now and they are completely infatuated with this.
这就是 DevOps 发挥作用的地方。我们也支持 Kubernetes，所以你可以在 Kubernetes 上运行整个技术栈。是的，我们使用 Kubernetes。我们也支持 Kubernetes，所以你可以在 Kubernetes 上运行整个技术栈。是的，我们可能会在生产环境中使用带有大量 GPU 的 Kubernetes 来提供我们自己的服务。太酷了。是的，这很迷人。好的，也许我们最后总结一下，对于现在正在收听并且完全迷上这个领域的人，有什么最后的建议？
They want to get into MLOps. We talked a little bit about things to study and all that, but in terms of maybe more of a mindset or kind of lessons you've learned on the soft skills side, what are some advice that you can give to folks out there who want to get into this field? Yeah, I mean, I would recommend joining the MLOps community
他们想进入 MLOps。我们讨论了一些要学习的东西等等，但就心态或你在软技能方面学到的教训而言，你能给那些想进入这个领域的人什么建议？是的，我的意思是，我会建议加入 MLOps 社区
or other communities to have peers to talk to about it. And then, yeah, I would say start playing with the technology. Like I said earlier, if you want to get into ML Ops, like play with Python, Git, Docker, PyTorch, that kind of thing.
或其他社区，以便有同行可以交流。然后，是的，我会说开始尝试这些技术。正如我之前所说，如果你想进入 MLOps，就去玩 Python、Git、Docker、PyTorch 之类的东西。
If you want to get into this newer field of LLM Ops, like how you manage RAG and API integrations kind of on the other side of the LLM API boundary, if that makes sense, then download Ollama and spin up an LLM locally. If you like, like play with Helix and set up like an API integration. And then that'll set you up well
如果你想进入这个较新的 LLM Ops 领域，比如你如何管理 RAG 和 API 集成，如果这说得通的话，那么下载 Ollama 并在本地启动一个 LLM。如果你愿意，去玩玩 Helix 并设置一个 API 集成。然后这将为你做好准备，
to be able to go into maybe like a job interview or something and say like, I've got this experience or to build a site project. Yeah, totally. Amazing advice. or something and say like i've got this experience or um or to build a site project yeah totally amazing advice i think uh we covered um we actually covered docker in the kubernetes episode which is uh you know we should have in hindsight maybe had a dedicated docker episode uh but check out the kubernetes episode if you haven't already uh we talk about minikube and there's probably better things out there that episode is a little dated now that's okay minikube's solid is this still the thing or there's kind as well that's right yeah used kind recently um but uh yeah get get set up on your
能够去参加工作面试之类的，并说我有这些经验，或者做一个副项目。是的，完全正确。很棒的建议。或者做一个副项目。是的，完全正确。很棒的建议。我想我们涵盖了……我们其实在 Kubernetes 那一集讨论了 Docker，这是……你知道，事后看来我们也许应该有一个专门的 Docker 剧集，但如果你还没听过，去看看 Kubernetes 那一集。我们讨论了 Minikube，外面可能有更好的东西，那一集现在有点过时了。没关系，Minikube 很稳。这还是主流吗？或者也有 Kind。没错，是的，最近用过 Kind，但……是的，在你的
machine and uh check out helix ml totally free uh for folks out there um if you're going to install it on your work computer and you work for like Google or some company that has a lot of revenue, you probably need to check with your boss first. Or just come talk to us on Discord. Yeah, or just talk. Yeah, exactly. If you're a hobbyist,
机器上设置好，去看看 Helix ML，对大家完全免费。如果你要把它安装在工作电脑上，而且你在谷歌或某些收入很高的公司工作，你可能需要先咨询你的老板。或者直接在 Discord 上和我们交流。是的，或者直接交流。是的，完全正确。如果你是一个业余爱好者，
just install it and get started and try things out. Yeah, awesome. Cool. All right. Thank you, Luke. Thank you so much for your time. It's been awesome. Thanks for having me on.
直接安装并开始尝试。是的，太棒了。酷。好的。谢谢你，Luke。非常感谢你的时间。这太棒了。谢谢你邀请我。
Cool. All right. So as part of this three-parter you know we uh we just had uh luke on to talk about um you know what is ml ops and kind of get us started on that and explain his story and now i'm really excited we have yuval fernbach here who's the cto of jfrog, and he's going to explain to us more about the whole kind of supply chain of AI software. So thanks so much for coming on the show, Yuval. Thank you. Thank you. And really nice to be here. Cool.
太棒了。好的。作为这个三部曲的一部分，我们刚刚邀请了 Luke 来谈谈什么是 MLOps，带我们入门并分享了他的故事。现在我非常高兴能请到 JFrog 的首席技术官 Yuval Fernbach，他将为我们详细讲解 AI 软件的整个供应链。非常感谢你来到节目，Yuval。谢谢。谢谢。很高兴能来到这里。太棒了。
Yeah. It's a pleasure to be here. Yeah. And just to recap, we are at the SwampUp conference, which is, I think, hosted by JFrog. Yeah, it's hosted by JFrog, and it's actually my first SwampUp, so I'm excited to be here. That is awesome. So before we dive into MLOps, why don't you tell us a little bit about your story? What kind of led you to JFrog?
是的，很高兴能来到这里。顺便回顾一下，我们现在是在 SwampUp 大会上，我想这是由 JFrog 主办的吧？是的，是由 JFrog 主办的。这也是我第一次参加 SwampUp，所以我很兴奋能来到这里。那太棒了。那么在深入探讨 MLOps 之前，你能给我们讲讲你的故事吗？是什么让你加入了 JFrog？
Sure. So previously, before joining JFrog, actually only two months ago, I was part of Quark. Quark is an MLOps platform, and I was one of the co-founders and CTO for Quark that was acquired by JFrog end of June and now basically part of JFrog ML. So before being part of Quark and founding Quark, I was working for Amazon Web Services for five years.
当然。在加入 JFrog 之前，其实也就是两个月前，我还在 Quark 工作。Quark 是一个 MLOps 平台，我是它的联合创始人兼首席技术官。Quark 在六月底被 JFrog 收购了，现在基本上是 JFrog ML 的一部分。在创立 Quark 之前，我在亚马逊云科技（AWS）工作了五年。
I was part of the AWS Machinery and Service team, basically working with the AWS customers on their challenges around machinery. So I've seen hundreds of customers, hundreds of companies trying to solve that, trying to understand how they can start iterating on machinery, building models, experimenting, and eventually impacting the business based on machining models and AI applications. And that's basically one of the main reasons why, together with my other
我当时是 AWS 机器学习服务团队的一员，主要负责与 AWS 客户合作，解决他们在机器学习方面遇到的挑战。我见过数百名客户和数百家公司试图解决这些问题，试图了解他们如何开始进行机器学习迭代、构建模型、进行实验，并最终基于机器学习模型和 AI 应用对业务产生影响。这基本上就是我和其他联合创始人决定创立 Quark 的主要原因之一，
co-founders, we decided to fund Quark and help those companies to actually achieve that, to make sure that they impact their business and build models, not just for the research or for the development, but actually making that supply chain work and affecting their production as well. Cool. So, you know, I think one really unique story I'd love to dive into is you're at AWS, which is a very large organization, right? Roughly how many people are there? How many engineers at AWS? Maybe tens of thousands?
我们想帮助这些公司真正实现这一目标，确保他们不仅是为了研究或开发而构建模型，而是真正让供应链运转起来，并对他们的生产环境产生影响。太棒了。我想深入探讨一个非常独特的故事，那就是你在 AWS 的经历，那是一个非常庞大的组织，对吧？大概有多少人？AWS 有多少工程师？可能有几万人吧？
I've been there for five years. And in that time, it changed from a few thousands to probably tens of thousands by the time I actually founded Quark. So it changed quite a lot. I'm not sure what are the numbers right now, but by the way, it was amazing to see how a company that was relatively small,
我在那里工作了五年。在那段时间里，它从几千人增长到我创立 Quark 时可能已经有几万人了。所以变化非常大。我不确定现在的具体数字，但顺便说一下，看到一家相对较小的公司，
at least versus Amazon, actually grew and became such an amazing business. Yeah, definitely. Yeah, I feel like the documentation, the quality of service of AWS, I haven't used other ones recently, but I remember, this is years and years ago, looking at all the different options
至少相对于亚马逊而言，能够成长并成为如此出色的业务，真是令人惊叹。是的，绝对是。我觉得 AWS 的文档和服务的质量，虽然我最近没用过其他的，但我记得那是多年前的事了，当时查看了所有不同的选项，
and just seeing just a higher level of quality for AWS. Things just tended to work and the documentation was really well done. And there's an extraordinary amount of effort and user study and things that go into that. Yeah, I must say that I learned a lot during that time because I've seen the company that basically founded the cloud or the first company that created the cloud
就觉得 AWS 的质量水平更高。事情往往就是能顺利运行，而且文档写得非常好。这背后投入了大量的努力、用户研究和心血。是的，我必须说我在那段时间学到了很多，因为我见证了这家基本上开创了云服务，或者说是第一家创造了云服务的公司，
that understood that their customers are not IT, their customers are developers that need to build software. And they build that as a self-service, basically product-led development before anyone talked about it. And I think that's one of the reasons why eventually we found the quack is that we saw how that company grew.
他们明白客户不是 IT 部门，而是需要构建软件的开发人员。他们以自助服务的方式构建了这些，这在当时还没人谈论“产品驱动开发”的时候就已经实现了。我认为这也是我们最终创立 Quark 的原因之一，因为我们看到了那家公司的成长。
There were so many services and it became really, really difficult for companies to actually utilize the different services. And not just utilize different services, but the challenges have grown. You cannot just utilize different services, but the challenges have grown. You cannot just use EC2 and S3 anymore. You need different high-level
当时有太多的服务，公司要真正利用这些不同的服务变得非常非常困难。不仅仅是利用不同的服务，挑战也增加了。你不能再只使用 EC2 和 S3 了。你需要不同的高级
solutions to make your product work. And I believe that it's amazing what AWS built. But nowadays I think that in many cases, using those building blocks directly
解决方案来让你的产品正常工作。我相信 AWS 构建的东西很棒。但如今我认为在很多情况下，直接使用这些构建模块
and trying to build on top of that is actually too much for many of the companies. And actually, the amount of investment that you need to do to actually do that, the amount of engineering work that you need to do to build, for example, an ML solution, is just too much for many of the companies. And it's really difficult to do
并试图在此基础上进行构建，对许多公司来说负担太重了。实际上，你需要投入的资金，以及为了构建例如机器学习解决方案而需要进行的工程工作量，对许多公司来说实在太多了。这真的很难做到。
that. Yeah, that makes sense. I kind of experienced this firsthand where you can stand up things with the web UI, you know, and so it's like, I want an EC2 instance, I want a database. But then at some point, you need to programmatically do that. It like oh i need a beta database and the beta database needs to have all the same things and you just you just forget what you clicked on a month ago so you need this infrastructure as code and then that's a rabbit hole and it's hard to hire people who have that talent and so it becomes difficult yeah yeah it's it's it's actually amazing to see how companies have grown to a place where they understand that it's not single-point solutions. You need to create platforms.
是的，这很有道理。我亲身经历过这一点，你可以通过 Web UI 搭建东西，比如“我想要一个 EC2 实例，我想要一个数据库”。但到了某个阶段，你需要以编程方式来做。比如“哦，我需要一个测试数据库，测试数据库需要具备所有相同的配置”，你根本记不住一个月前点击了什么，所以你需要这种“基础设施即代码”，然后这就变成了一个无底洞，而且很难雇到有这种天赋的人，所以变得很困难。是的，确实如此。看到公司发展到意识到这不仅仅是单点解决方案，而是需要创建平台，这真的很神奇。
So, for example, going to the software supply chain, understanding how a software supply chain looks like, it's not just a CI, CD. It's your source code and how you manage your binaries and then how the security infrastructure looks like on top and then why software engineering is different than data science and how it's all connected to the same supply chain. And eventually, this challenge is not just, you know,
例如，谈到软件供应链，了解软件供应链的样子，它不仅仅是 CI/CD。它是你的源代码，你如何管理二进制文件，然后安全基础设施在上面是什么样子，以及为什么软件工程与数据科学不同，以及它们如何连接到同一个供应链。最终，这个挑战不仅仅是，你知道，
spin-up instances and databases and writing code in Git. It's way more than that. It's having a system that can actually work in scale and allow your company to be efficient both in, you know, once you have like two, three, five, 10 developers, but the same efficiency once you have thousands of developers and you want to actually make sure
启动实例和数据库，在 Git 中编写代码。它远不止于此。它需要一个能够真正规模化运行的系统，并允许你的公司在拥有两、三、五、十名开发人员时保持高效，在拥有数千名开发人员时也能保持同样的效率，并且你想要确保
that you deliver on time and not just deliver on time, but you delivered a trust for the products, products that you can trust both in terms of the features but also in terms of the security and make sure that they work in production exactly the way that they should
你能按时交付，而且不仅是按时交付，交付的还是值得信赖的产品，这些产品在功能上值得信赖，在安全性上也值得信赖，并确保它们在生产环境中完全按照
based on the real product spec, for example. That makes sense. You went from giant company to Quark. I'm assuming maybe a handful of people when it started. Yeah, sure. Yeah, and so...
基于真实产品规范的方式运行。这很有道理。你从大公司转到了 Quark。我假设刚开始时可能只有几个人。是的，当然。是的，所以……
When it started, you know, it was four people, but of course we grew over time. Yeah, so was there sort of a shock, you know, the moment you went to Quark and you're like, wait, there's no IT department. There's just me, you know? Like, how did you navigate that? Because I know a lot of people who go from big to small company.
刚开始时，你知道，只有四个人，但随着时间推移我们当然成长了。是的，那么当你去 Quark 时，有没有一种冲击感，比如“等等，没有 IT 部门。只有我，你知道吗？”你是如何应对的？因为我知道很多人从大公司跳到小公司。
And there is a risk. Like, there's some people where it just doesn't work out. And I mean, that's okay. They go back to Facebook or whatever. But, you know, what was that experience like for you? You know, there's always a risk. And I think that founding a company, being one of the co-founders or even one of the first employees
这确实有风险。有些人可能就是适应不了。我的意思是，那也没关系。他们可以回到 Facebook 之类的公司。但是，那段经历对你来说是什么样的？你知道，总是有风险的。我认为创立一家公司，成为联合创始人之一，甚至是第一批员工之一，
is not for everyone and that's great because I think that the challenges that you have doing that are different challenges, different experiences than working with a giant company like Amazon. So I personally love it. I think it's
并不适合每个人，这很好，因为我认为这样做所面临的挑战，与在像亚马逊这样的巨头公司工作是完全不同的挑战和经历。所以我个人很喜欢。我认为这
an amazing experience. I love the fact that it was on me. Like, if I had a problem with my computer, I needed to fix it. I needed to talk with, you know, the person that we bought the computer from. I needed, so, you know, it's part of, like, the experience
是一种很棒的经历。我喜欢一切都由我负责的感觉。比如，如果我的电脑出了问题，我需要自己修。我需要和我们购买电脑的人沟通。所以我认为，这是
of founding a company, being part of a small organization, a startup. So I really love it, but, of course, it's not for everyone. And I think that one of the challenges is that you need to make sure that you focus on the right things, the right challenges, because there are many things to do, but your main goal is always to build a successful company
创立公司、成为小型组织或初创公司一部分的体验。所以我真的很喜欢，但当然，这并不适合每个人。我认为挑战之一是你需要确保专注于正确的事情，正确的挑战，因为有很多事情要做，但你的主要目标始终是建立一家成功的公司，
and make sure that your customers actually get the benefits of your product. The customers are actually happy with the solution that they get and want to use you and, of course, recommend you to their friends and colleagues. Yeah, that makes sense. So maybe before we jump into the ML Ops, what was Quark? What did Quark do and what does Quark continue to do through the acquisition? So, as I said, Quark was founded four years ago and we started from day one to focus on
并确保你的客户真正从你的产品中受益。客户对他们得到的解决方案感到满意，愿意使用你的产品，当然，还会向他们的朋友和同事推荐你。是的，这很有道理。那么在进入 MLOps 之前，Quark 是什么？Quark 做了什么，以及通过收购，Quark 继续在做什么？正如我所说，Quark 成立于四年前，我们从第一天起就专注于
this challenge called MLMs. So basically allowing companies to start from the development to the production without the need to manage multiple solutions, multiple platforms, and even utilizing or actually handshaking the code between different stakeholders during that process. So from day one, our main focus was production, how to make sure that models will work in production, and of course, going left or going back from production
这个被称为 MLOps 的挑战。基本上是让公司能够从开发到生产，而无需管理多种解决方案、多个平台，甚至在过程中不需要在不同利益相关者之间进行代码交接。从第一天起，我们的主要重点就是生产，如何确保模型在生产中正常工作，当然，从生产向回追溯，
on how you can make sure that the supply chain actually works from the development to the production and smoothly as possible. So we started with that. And I think that one of the challenges with MLOps is that it's not just around the models. It's around the data as well. So you need to both have that solution for data that
确保供应链从开发到生产尽可能顺畅。我们就是从这里开始的。我认为 MLOps 的挑战之一是它不仅仅关乎模型。它也关乎数据。所以你需要为数据提供解决方案，
allows you to, again, have data for production, have data for inference, but also data for training and have the way to manage that data, those features. The same way as you do that for models, and of course, nowadays, the same way that you do it for Gen AI applications,
这不仅能让你拥有用于生产的数据、用于推理的数据，还能拥有用于训练的数据，并拥有管理这些数据和特征的方法。就像你管理模型一样，当然，如今，你也可以用同样的方式处理生成式 AI 应用、
LLMs, things that are a bit different by nature, but eventually are based on the same infrastructure and the same questions and answers to evaluate the model. Well, it's going to be pretty, pretty good. And so that might sound like obvious, but it's actually really difficult to not accidentally leak the label. It's so difficult to keep sacrosanct like your evaluation set and keep it from accidentally, especially when you're doing aggregations at so many levels, from accidentally sort of poisoning the well. I fully agree.
大语言模型，这些本质上略有不同，但最终都是基于相同的基础设施，以及评估模型的相同问答方式。嗯，这会非常非常棒。这听起来可能很显而易见，但实际上很难做到不意外地泄露标签。保持评估集的纯洁性，防止它被意外污染，尤其是在进行多层聚合时，真的非常困难。我完全同意。
And I think that like having the proper data platform for AI and machinery applications is actually crucial because it's not just making sure that you manage the data set right and understand what's the difference between a training data set and evaluation data set. And I agree that's crucial because that's the only way for you to understand the metric of a model. It's also understanding that the data that you build the model on is actually available
我认为拥有一个适合 AI 和机器学习应用的正确数据平台至关重要，因为这不仅仅是确保你正确管理数据集，并理解训练数据集和评估数据集之间的区别。我同意这至关重要，因为这是你理解模型指标的唯一途径。它还意味着要理解你构建模型所依据的数据在
during prediction, during inference. So, and by the way, this is I think one of the reasons that many ML projects fail is because their scientists are doing research on the data. They get the data from the data warehouse. They train the model, but eventually
预测和推理过程中确实是可用的。顺便说一下，我认为这是许多机器学习项目失败的原因之一，因为科学家们在数据上进行研究。他们从数据仓库获取数据。他们训练模型，但最终
that data doesn't exist during prediction. It doesn't exist during inference. And many projects fail because they created an amazing model, but they don't have this data when the application needs it, when the application calls the model. The application doesn't know, I don't know, the history about that specific persona during that time and cannot get that because maybe it wasn't calculated yet.
这些数据在预测时并不存在。在推理时不存在。许多项目失败是因为他们创建了一个很棒的模型，但当应用需要它时，当应用调用模型时，他们却没有这些数据。应用不知道，我不知道，关于那个特定人物在那个时间点的历史记录，并且无法获取，因为可能还没计算出来。
And one of the things that we started with in Quark is to create a feature platform that allowed to create both an offline feature store and an online feature store that are basically based on the same calculation. The online feature store allowed to get a low latency current value of your features, while the offline feature are allowed to get
我们在 Quark 开始做的事情之一就是创建一个特征平台，允许创建离线特征存储和在线特征存储，它们基本上基于相同的计算。在线特征存储允许获取特征的低延迟当前值，而离线特征存储允许获取
all that training data that was calculated exactly the same. So you know that there is no basically drift between your offline or training data and your inference data. It's exactly the same. It was calculated the same. And the data that you are trained on is actually available during inference.
所有那些计算方式完全相同的训练数据。所以你知道你的离线或训练数据与推理数据之间基本上没有偏差。它们完全一样。计算方式相同。而且你训练所用的数据在推理时确实是可用的。
Yeah, I mean, the story I always tell folks was there was this product called Google+. It died along with a whole bunch of other Google products, but we were doing the friend suggest and a bunch of ML stuff for Google+, a long time ago. And there was an issue where the day of week feature was zero based at training and one based at serving and so sunday didn't exist and saturday i guess also didn't exist i don't remember exactly what happened with saturday i think it was a one hot encoding yeah so sunday and saturday both
是的，我总是告诉人们的一个故事是，曾经有一个叫 Google+ 的产品。它和其他许多谷歌产品一起死掉了，但很久以前我们曾为 Google+ 做过好友推荐和一堆机器学习的东西。当时出现了一个问题，星期几这个特征在训练时是从 0 开始计数的，而在服务时是从 1 开始计数的，所以星期天不存在，我想星期六也不存在，我不记得星期六具体发生了什么，我想那是独热编码（one-hot encoding），是的，所以星期天和星期六都
didn't exist and it caused all kinds of chaos and it was extremely difficult to find because you just would give bad suggestions on the weekend and and there's no compiler error there's there's no uh easy way to find they're written in two different languages you know the trading and the serving system so uh so yeah i think there was a product feast which was a very early attempt at this um but um yeah how has that evolved? Is it to the point now where you can write it once and it works on both? Again, I believe that the feature storage
不存在，这导致了各种混乱，而且极难发现，因为你只是在周末给出糟糕的建议，而且没有编译器错误，没有简单的方法可以找到，因为它们是用两种不同的语言编写的，你知道，训练系统和推理系统。所以，是的，我认为当时有一个叫 Feast 的产品，这是这方面非常早期的尝试，但是，是的，它现在是如何演变的？现在是否已经到了可以写一次代码，然后在两者上都能运行的地步？再次强调，我相信特征存储
is a crucial part of an email platform. And Feast, by the way, is an open source that still exists. But I think that one of the main challenges with such solutions like Feast, like the cloud vendor solutions for feature storage, that it's not just about the storage. It's about the data pipeline as well.
是机器学习平台至关重要的一部分。顺便说一下，Feast 是一个仍然存在的开源项目。但我认为像 Feast 这样的解决方案，以及云厂商的特征存储解决方案，主要挑战之一在于它不仅仅关乎存储。它还关乎数据流水线。
You need to have a data pipeline that eventually can connect both the offline and the online on a single process. So you write your code once in the same language, and that code will be used to create the data for both. And again, it's really connected to what you just said because in the past, many models were, for example, written in Python, but then the production implementation was, let's say, in C or Java or whatever, and you needed to recreate the features in a different language, and
你需要有一个最终能在单一流程中连接离线和在线的数据流水线。这样你就可以用同一种语言编写一次代码，而该代码将用于为两者创建数据。这确实和你刚才说的很相关，因为在过去，许多模型是用 Python 编写的，但生产实现可能是用 C 或 Java 或其他语言，你需要用不同的语言重新创建特征，而且
there is no actual way to compare the two and understand that the features were created the same. So many companies had the same challenge that you just talked about of having that, you know, that difference between the production and the training. And again, it's the same challenge with a feature store that are only the storage level like FIS and like others
没有实际的方法来比较两者并确保特征创建方式相同。所以许多公司都遇到了你刚才提到的那种在生产和训练之间存在差异的挑战。同样，对于像 Feast 和其他仅在存储层面的特征存储，也存在同样的挑战，
because you need to have that same data processing layer that will be used to create both features. And I must say that part of it is that Python now actually grew enough to be good enough for production, because in many cases, it's not really Python production. You build a model in Python, but then eventually it's a C object that's running in production, although the code is in Python. So you can actually use the same code and get pretty good performance.
因为你需要有相同的数据处理层来创建这两个特征。我必须说，其中一部分原因是 Python 现在已经发展到足以胜任生产环境了，因为在很多情况下，它并不是真正的 Python 生产环境。你在 Python 中构建模型，但最终它是一个在生产中运行的 C 对象，尽管代码是 Python 的。所以你实际上可以使用相同的代码并获得相当不错的性能。
So that's, of course, part of the technology enhancement that happened during those years. Oh, very cool. So a lot of projects start with Jupyter Notebook, which is kind of itself kind of this extension or descendant of Mathematica, right? Mathematica notebook, which is this beautiful, like, you know, interactive thing.
所以这当然是这些年来技术进步的一部分。哦，太酷了。所以很多项目都是从 Jupyter Notebook 开始的，它本身就是 Mathematica 的一种扩展或后代，对吧？Mathematica 笔记本，这是一种非常漂亮的、交互式的东西。
And it just becomes really hard then to, to, to productionize that because it's not dot pi files, it's all these cells. And, and so how do you recommend for folks to, to go from that notebook to something that can run at scale? So it's a great question because I needed to talk about supply chain. And that question eventually pivoted me back to supply chain. And I love notebooks. I think that notebooks are great for some things. For example, if I want to visualize data, if I want to have an interactive environment, notebooks are amazing for that.
然后要将其产品化就变得非常困难，因为它不是 .py 文件，而是所有这些单元格。那么，你建议人们如何从笔记本过渡到可以规模化运行的东西？这是一个很好的问题，因为我需要谈谈供应链。这个问题最终把我带回了供应链。我喜欢笔记本。我认为笔记本在某些方面很棒。例如，如果我想可视化数据，如果我想拥有一个交互式环境，笔记本在这方面非常棒。
By the way, IDs are amazing for other things. For example, debugging code, IDs are way better for that than notebooks. There are advantages for each one of them, but both are not built for production. Eventually, when you want to build for production, you need to have a proper CI. You need to have a proper supply chain
顺便说一下，IDE 在其他方面非常棒。例如，调试代码，IDE 在这方面比笔记本好得多。它们各有优势，但两者都不是为生产而构建的。最终，当你想要为生产构建时，你需要一个合适的 CI。你需要一个合适的供应链，
that moves that code to be an artifact and from being an artifact, eventually deploy that. And of course, making sure that you have a lineage between the deployment, the artifact, the source code, all that should be connected in a way. So what I've seen is that notebooks are great, are amazing, but eventually once companies understand or graduate to the place
将代码转化为制品，并从制品最终部署它。当然，确保你在部署、制品、源代码之间有血缘关系，所有这些都应该以某种方式连接起来。所以我看到的是，笔记本很棒，很神奇，但最终一旦公司理解或升级到
that they want to be to production, they need to add more structure to the way they build the models. And for example, one of the things that we've done in Quark and now with J4ML is to have an opinionated way of how to build models in terms of structure that allow every new data scientist to look
他们想要进入生产环境的阶段，他们就需要为构建模型的方式增加更多的结构。例如，我们在 Quark 以及现在的 JFrog ML 所做的事情之一，就是拥有一种关于如何构建模型的结构化观点，允许每一位新的数据科学家查看
at the model that they never looked on before and understand, okay, this is the training of the model. This is the code for the inference. This is the code that fetches the data from the feature store. Like, immediately understand the structure of a model, immediately understand how that model was built and be able to help
他们从未看过的模型，并理解：“好的，这是模型的训练部分。这是推理代码。这是从特征存储中获取数据的代码。”就像立即理解模型的结构，立即理解模型是如何构建的，并且仅仅通过查看代码和结构，就能够帮助
or train a model that they haven't seen before just by looking at the code and looking at that structure. So I believe that notebook, it's part of the research, but in some phase you need to move from the notebook to have that
或训练一个他们以前没见过的模型。所以我相信笔记本是研究的一部分，但在某个阶段，你需要从笔记本过渡到拥有
code managed, for example, in a source version solution, so let's say in a Git solution, in a way that can actually be automated. So you need to have some kind of structure of what the training job looks like, what the prediction looks like, what the depends,
受管理的代码，例如，在源代码版本控制解决方案中，比如 Git 解决方案中，以一种可以自动化的方式。所以你需要某种关于训练作业是什么样子、预测是什么样子、依赖项是什么样子的结构，
well, the depends is which packages you need to run that model, because packages, especially in Python, a new version can come out and break everything so you need to actually freeze those dependencies to make sure that you have that model actually reproducible and not just
嗯，依赖项是指运行该模型所需的包，因为包，特别是在 Python 中，新版本出来可能会破坏一切，所以你需要实际冻结这些依赖项，以确保你的模型实际上是可重现的，而不仅仅是
train once on a notebook on someone's computer and will never work again yeah definitely and you have to be able to go back as well like we did these really hacky things but there's got to be able to go back as well like uh um we did this these really hacky things but there's got to be a principled way like once you've you you have it in source control and it's in production you're always going to want to do more data science because you are going to change
在某人的电脑上的笔记本中训练一次，然后就再也无法运行了。是的，绝对是。而且你必须能够回溯，就像我们做这些非常黑客式的操作一样，但必须有一种原则性的方法，一旦你将其放入源代码控制并投入生产，你总是会想要做更多的数据科学工作，因为你将会改变
the product the product changes without you because new customers adopt and some uh uh churn and everything. And so being able to run a Jupyter notebook on your production code and then make changes, that whole integration is extremely complicated and so valuable. Yeah, yeah. Models degrade over time. That's, I think, the way a model looks like
产品，产品会在你不知情的情况下发生变化，因为新客户加入，一些客户流失等等。因此，能够在生产代码上运行 Jupyter Notebook 然后进行更改，整个集成过程极其复杂，但也极其有价值。是的，是的。模型会随着时间推移而退化。我认为这就是模型的样子，
because data changes over time. So part I think the way a model looks like, because data changes over time. So part of having the structure, so by the way, one of the things, for example, that we do with J4ML now is that whenever I build a model, I automatically basically copy or freeze the
因为数据会随时间变化。所以，我认为模型的样子，因为数据会随时间变化。所以，拥有结构的一部分，顺便说一下，例如，我们现在用 JFrog ML 所做的事情之一是，每当我构建一个模型时，我都会自动复制或冻结
source code that I used to build that model, I freeze the dependencies that were used to build that model, I create the model artifact, the trained model, but I can reproduce that model at any point in time. I know which configuration I used, I know what was the source code I used, I know what is the data set I used, and I
我用来构建该模型的源代码，我冻结了用于构建该模型的依赖项，我创建了模型制品，即训练好的模型，但我可以在任何时间点重现该模型。我知道我使用了什么配置，我知道我使用的源代码是什么，我知道我使用的数据集是什么，而且我
think this is a practice that companies must utilize. Practices must make sure that they have the ability to reproduce a model because they will need to train that model again. They will need to fine-tune it. They will need to
认为这是公司必须采用的做法。实践必须确保他们有能力重现模型，因为他们将需要再次训练该模型。他们将需要对其进行微调。他们将需要
understand, even without model monitoring, even without really looking at the data and seeing the drift, it probably happens. And if it happens, it means that they will need to retrain that, and they will need to have the structure that allow them to retrain that
理解，即使没有模型监控，即使没有真正查看数据并看到偏差，它也可能发生了。如果发生了，这意味着他们将需要重新训练它，并且他们需要拥有允许他们重新训练它的结构，
even if the data science that build that is not available anymore, is not in the company or just your team grew and you have more projects. Yeah, that makes sense. So on episode 158, we actually had Bill Manning from JFrog
即使构建它的数据科学家不再可用，不在公司了，或者只是你的团队扩大了，你有更多的项目。是的，这很有道理。在第 158 期节目中，我们实际上邀请了 JFrog 的 Bill Manning
come on the show and talk about software supply chains. And so folks should definitely listen to that episode if you haven't already. So what's the delta between that and AI supply chains? How does AI kind of make that problem different? So first of all, the process itself looks different. So, first of all, the process itself looks different. Like, an ML project starts from research, it starts from experiments, you need
来到节目中谈论软件供应链。所以如果大家还没听过那期节目，一定要去听。那么，这与 AI 供应链之间的增量是什么？AI 是如何让这个问题变得不同的？首先，过程本身看起来就不同。首先，过程本身看起来就不同。比如，一个机器学习项目从研究开始，从实验开始，你需要
to track those experiments. Those are phases that do not exist with software. Usually, when you build software, it happens because of two reasons. First, you have a new feature, and second, you have a bug. So, those are the reasons why you start working on a software project. But with ML, it's also because your data has changed.
跟踪这些实验。这些阶段在软件开发中是不存在的。通常，当你构建软件时，发生这种情况有两个原因。第一，你有新功能；第二，你有 Bug。所以，这些是你开始从事软件项目的原因。但对于机器学习，这也是因为你的数据发生了变化。
It's also because you have more features and you want to make that model better. So there are many reasons why to work on an ML project, and it always starts with some kind of research experiment. And those phases look entirely different in terms of AROps, MLOs. Same for the deployed model because the monitoring that you do for software
也是因为你有更多的特征，你想让模型变得更好。所以从事机器学习项目的原因有很多，而且它总是从某种研究实验开始。这些阶段在 MLOps 方面看起来完全不同。对于已部署的模型也是如此，因为你为软件所做的监控
is only the infrastructure monitoring, maybe logs analysis, maybe understanding if there are bugs and what are the latencies of different processes and those kinds of things. But with models, you actually need to monitor the data as well. You need to monitor the model and make sure that this model
只是基础设施监控，可能是日志分析，可能是了解是否有 Bug 以及不同进程的延迟等等。但对于模型，你实际上还需要监控数据。你需要监控模型并确保该模型
actually gives the right impact on the business. Make sure that this model doesn't degrade over time. So the process itself looks a bit differently, but eventually what happens in the software supply chain process is that you have code, then you create artifacts, and then you deploy those artifacts. And those parts are the same with AI, with ML. Maybe some configurations are different.
确实对业务产生了正确的影响。确保该模型不会随时间推移而退化。所以过程本身看起来有点不同，但最终在软件供应链过程中发生的事情是，你有代码，然后你创建制品，然后你部署这些制品。这些部分在 AI 和机器学习中是一样的。也许一些配置不同。
Maybe, for example, nowadays with AI, you have also prompts as part of your artifact. Maybe you have an external model like, I don't know, ChatGPT or something like that, and there is a new version. And it's not something that you manage, but it's still an API that you call, it's still an application that you need to manage. So eventually it's the same artifacts behind the scenes,
也许，例如，如今有了 AI，你还有提示词（prompts）作为制品的一部分。也许你有一个外部模型，比如 ChatGPT 之类的，并且有一个新版本。这不是你管理的，但它仍然是你调用的 API，它仍然是你需要管理的应用程序。所以最终幕后是相同的制品，
same idea, but different processes. And even the security posture, even the understanding if a model is trusted enough, is trustworthy, that's pretty much the same as any other kind of software. So if you build software and you scan those software and you scan the dependencies and you scan your runtime environment
相同的想法，但不同的过程。甚至安全态势，甚至理解一个模型是否足够可信，是否值得信赖，这与任何其他类型的软件几乎是一样的。所以如果你构建软件，你扫描这些软件，你扫描依赖项，你扫描运行时环境，
and you want to make sure that the same software that you build in runtime don't have vulnerabilities and you scan it from the source code and up to the right time and understand how your security posture looks like, it should look the same with machine learning because eventually those are packages, those are artifacts and third-party APIs that need to be secured and need to make sure that you manage that lifecycle in a way that you trust. Yeah,
并且你想要确保你在运行时构建的相同软件没有漏洞，并且你从源代码一直扫描到运行时，并了解你的安全态势是什么样子，机器学习也应该看起来一样，因为最终这些都是包，这些都是制品和第三方 API，需要被保护，并且需要确保你以一种你信任的方式管理该生命周期。是的，
that makes sense. This was awesome. Thank you so much for your time. This was really great. One last thing you have for students who want to get into this field. What's some advice you could give them? So, first of all, it's an amazing field, so do it. It's great advice. But second is that I think nowadays with all
这很有道理。这太棒了。非常感谢你的时间。这真的很棒。最后，对于想要进入这个领域的学生，你有什么建议吗？首先，这是一个很棒的领域，所以去做吧。这是很好的建议。但第二点是，我认为如今有了所有
the Gen AI models and LMs, the entrance point is actually easier than in the past. Like in the past, you needed to understand the statistics around the data and you needed to add this data to start training models. And there was quite a lot of understanding, quite a lot of
生成式 AI 模型和大语言模型，入门点实际上比过去更容易了。在过去，你需要理解数据周围的统计学，你需要添加这些数据来开始训练模型。而且有相当多的理解，相当多的
work you needed to do to actually have a model ready. And nowadays you can start understanding that just by using, for example, ChatGPT. I think that as an example, my father only now understands what I do because he understands ChatGPT. He saw what it looks like and what are the effects of models.
工作需要你去做才能真正拥有一个准备好的模型。而如今，你可以通过使用例如 ChatGPT 来开始理解这一点。我认为作为一个例子，我父亲直到现在才明白我在做什么，因为他理解 ChatGPT。他看到了它看起来是什么样子，以及模型的效果是什么。
So I believe that this is a great starting point for every student that wants to start learning about machining, about AI, play with those tools. Understand our specific prompt change, change the way the model reacts, and eventually, those are models that are maybe more complicated than the models that we've done five years ago
所以我相信对于每一个想要开始学习机器学习、AI 的学生来说，这是一个很好的起点，去玩这些工具。理解我们的特定提示词是如何改变模型反应方式的，最终，这些模型可能比我们五年前所做的模型更复杂，
that we use for specific point solutions. But eventually, those are models that use the same technologies behind the scenes. And understanding how those models behave will give you quite a lot of knowledge about what the development looks like and how you can utilize machine learning
我们当时用于特定的单点解决方案。但最终，这些模型在幕后使用了相同的技术。理解这些模型的行为将为你提供关于开发是什么样子以及你如何利用机器学习的相当多的知识
for every kind of task. Very cool. Thank you so much, Yuval. I really appreciate your time. Thank you very much. All right, everyone. So we have been talking in this episode about ML Ops. And I'm really lucky that we have Steven Shin on the phone, who's done a lot of really interesting work with this. And we're going to focus on LLMs and GraphRag as kind of two case studies of getting ML and AI implemented, and then what that whole process is like, and then getting all of that into the hands of customers. So welcome, Stephen. Thanks for coming
来完成各种任务。太酷了。非常感谢你，Yuval。我真的很感谢你的时间。非常感谢。好的，各位。所以我们在这一集中一直在谈论 MLOps。我很幸运，我们电话连线了 Steven Shin，他在这个领域做了很多非常有趣的工作。我们将重点关注大语言模型（LLM）和 GraphRag 作为两个案例研究，了解机器学习和 AI 的实施，以及整个过程是什么样的，然后将所有这些交付到客户手中。所以欢迎 Stephen。感谢你来到
on the show. No, very glad to be here and excited that I'm speaking at SwapUp actually on the same topic. So I'm going to be talking a bit about knowledge graphs plus LLMs, and in particular, how you can apply them to your DevOps pipeline. Cool. So before we jump into all of that, why don't you give us a quick background? What was your path that kind of led you to where you are now? And what are you doing right now? Yeah, so maybe we'll start with where I am and go backwards. So I'm VP of developer Relations at Neo4j. Neo4j is a graph database company, but also does a lot
节目。不客气，很高兴来到这里，也很兴奋我能在 SwapUp 上谈论同一个话题。所以我将谈论一点知识图谱加 LLM，特别是你如何将它们应用到你的 DevOps 流水线中。太棒了。那么在深入探讨所有这些之前，你能给我们一个简短的背景介绍吗？是什么路径让你走到了现在的位置？你现在在做什么？是的，也许我们从我所在的位置开始，然后倒叙。我是 Neo4j 的开发者关系副总裁。Neo4j 是一家图数据库公司，但也做了很多
with generative AI and machine learning and is building out architectures for GraphRack that a lot of enterprises are using. Before this, I was working at JFrog for basically the same role, VP of developer relations.
关于生成式 AI 和机器学习的工作，并且正在为许多企业正在使用的 GraphRag 构建架构。在此之前，我基本上在 JFrog 担任相同的职位，即开发者关系副总裁。
And I did this Oracle, slightly different role, but basically the same role. I was running the developer marketing team. And the way I kind of got into developer relations in general, because I was also a developer advocate for a bunch of years is um i made the mistake okay of writing a book oh okay um now i'm not discouraging anybody from writing books it's a wonderful way to increase your reputation to like like teach and explain things which you're passionate about to a larger audience um and when i wrote the book i i was um fortunate enough to have a some great co-authors who i collaborated with on the title um it's a lot of work you're basically like giving away six months to a year of your life where you have no weekends no evenings especially if you have a
我在 Oracle 做过，职位略有不同，但基本上是同一个角色。我负责开发者营销团队。我进入开发者关系领域的方式，因为我也做了很多年的开发者倡导者，是因为……我犯了一个错误，好的，写了一本书。哦，好的……现在我并不是在劝阻任何人写书，这是一种提高声誉、教导和向更广泛的受众解释你所热衷的事物的绝佳方式……当我写这本书时，我足够幸运，有一些很棒的合著者，我和他们合作完成了这个标题……这需要做很多工作，你基本上是放弃了你生命中的六个月到一年，没有周末，没有晚上，特别是如果你还有一份
day job that you also have to keep going um and then when you finally finish the book the publisher says has oh that's a wonderful book we've released it on you know amazon bookstores etc but can you help us promote it oh you become the promotion arm for the book like if you're not submitting to conferences and talking on a topic if you're not book. Like if you're not submitting to conferences and talking on a topic, if you're not on social media, if you're not like out there being a vocal advocate for the technologies you care about. And,
必须继续做的日常工作……然后当你最终完成这本书时，出版商说：“哦，那是一本很棒的书，我们已经在亚马逊书店等平台上发布了，但你能帮我们推广它吗？”哦，你成了这本书的推广部门。如果你不向会议提交议题并在某个主题上发言，如果你不在社交媒体上，如果你不出去成为你所关心的技术的直言不讳的倡导者。而且，
and you know, obviously, you know, pointing out that there might be a good book that folks can read for more information, then you're not doing your job. Now that, that first book I wrote,
你知道，显然，你知道，指出可能有一本好书供人们阅读以获取更多信息，那么你就没有做好你的工作。现在，我写的第一本书，
Oh my God, it must have been i'm dating myself like 15 years ago so you knew a technology and and the uh a publisher approached you and said you know steven you uh are really gifted in this technology why don't you write a book on it that's kind of how that went down yeah and actually that when i when i was in um college i assumed it was the opposite i assumed like you wrote a book and you went to publishers and you said look at this great like book that i wrote would you want to would you want to would you want to put this onto your brand and publish it but no no publishers especially tech publishers work exactly the opposite they have a a roadmap these are the
天哪，那一定是我在暴露自己的年龄，大概是 15 年前了。所以你了解一项技术，然后出版商找到你说：“你知道，Steven，你在这项技术上非常有天赋，为什么不写一本关于它的书呢？”事情就是这样发生的。是的，实际上，当我在大学时，我以为情况正好相反。我以为是你写了一本书，然后去找出版商说：“看看这本我写的很棒的书，你想把它放在你的品牌下出版吗？”但不是，不是，出版商，特别是技术出版商，工作方式完全相反。他们有一个路线图，这些是
titles we want to publish these the topics that matter to us occasionally you can influence that but not until you're an established author you have really good relationships with the editorial group and they then say okay for these for these books we want to author for these titles we want to author who who would be a good candidate like who has the expertise the who can authoritatively write a book and and help us market it later on and so you had the footprint then that they were able to find you so you had done some kind of promotion to get to that point yeah so i mean it was for java effects technology and i i got in really early, like beta days.
我们想要出版的标题，这些是对我们很重要的主题。偶尔你可以影响这一点，但直到你成为一名成熟的作者，你与编辑组有很好的关系，他们然后说：“好的，对于这些书，我们想要作者；对于这些标题，我们想要作者，谁会是一个好的候选人？谁拥有专业知识？谁能权威地写一本书，并在以后帮助我们营销它？”所以你当时有影响力，他们能够找到你，所以你已经做了一些推广才达到那个点。是的，所以我的意思是，那是针对 JavaFX 技术，我进入得非常早，就像测试版时期。
I was already building applications with it, had a lot of good connections in the JavaFX community, and I got invited with somebody else who'd written another book with the same publisher, and now this was the first real JavaFX book. Now, fast forward 15 years later, and we got asked to update basically the same title for Java 21 and 23 with all the latest features and capabilities. So it's become, for this small niche market, JavaFX,
我已经在使用它构建应用程序了，在 JavaFX 社区中有很多很好的联系，我被邀请与另一位与同一出版商写过另一本书的人合作，现在这是第一本真正的 JavaFX 书。现在，快进 15 年，我们被要求为 Java 21 和 23 更新基本上相同的标题，包含所有最新的功能和能力。所以它已经成为，对于这个小众市场，JavaFX，
which I don't actually do professionally anymore, but I still keep up on it, and I'm very close with the community. This has basically become the authoritative guide for client developers in Java. Wow. I'm totally dating myself here, but the last time I professionally wrote Java, it was this thing called Google Web Toolkit.
虽然我现在不再从事专业开发，但我仍保持关注，并与社区保持密切联系。这基本上已经成为 Java 客户端开发者的权威指南。哇。我完全暴露了自己的年龄，但我最后一次专业编写 Java 代码时，用的是一种叫 Google Web Toolkit 的东西。
Oh, yeah. And you would create JavaScript with Java. This was one of these, in hindsight, in my opinion, really bad ideas. I mean, maybe not. And I was writing, I think, in Java 6 or something, and it was compiled to JavaScript. It's kind of a really strange... I mean, that was my first introduction to Java.
哦，是的。你可以用 Java 创建 JavaScript。回想起来，在我看来，这真的是个馊主意。我是说，也许也不一定。当时我大概是在用 Java 6 左右的版本编写代码，然后它被编译成 JavaScript。这真是一种非常奇怪的……我是说，那是我第一次接触 Java。
Yeah, GWT was kind of an interesting approach. I think we've come a long way there with JavaScript frameworks which do all the heavy lifting. So basically you can have a very feature-rich application without a heavyweight backend. So I think that's
是的，GWT 确实是一种有趣的尝试。我认为我们在 JavaScript 框架方面已经取得了长足的进步，它们承担了所有繁重的工作。所以基本上，你可以在没有重量级后端的情况下拥有一个功能非常丰富的应用程序。所以我认为这就是
become the modern development framework. GWT was an attempt to do that, have the heavy front ends, but then have you write it entirely in Java and then deploy all that JavaScript magically and have the web application just appear. It's technically difficult to do that perfectly, and therefore it couldn't keep up
现代开发框架的发展方向。GWT 曾试图做到这一点，拥有重量级的前端，但让你完全用 Java 编写，然后神奇地部署所有 JavaScript，让 Web 应用程序直接呈现出来。要完美做到这一点在技术上很难，因此它无法跟上
with modern JavaScript frameworks. Yeah, and then on the other end, it really got squeezed by Node because the advantage of GWT was, for example, you could write validators in Java and validate the client side and the server side. But now you can do that with JavaScript.
现代 JavaScript 框架的步伐。是的，而且在另一方面，它确实受到了 Node 的挤压，因为 GWT 的优势在于，例如，你可以用 Java 编写验证器，并在客户端和服务器端进行验证。但现在你可以用 JavaScript 做到这一点。
And again, for reference, the Google team accepted and endorsed the use of GWT and GWT for the same acronym so they would use both ah yeah they never agreed upon what it was supposed to make sense um cool so okay fast forwarding all the way to to current time so you are actually before we dive into LLMs let's talk about this a a little bit. So what is a developer relations advocate and someone who leads a team of advocates? What is that job? Because we're going to dive into a lot of technical content here.
再说一次，作为参考，谷歌团队接受并认可了 GWT 和 GWT 使用同一个缩写，所以他们两者都用，啊，是的，他们从未就这到底意味着什么达成一致，嗯，酷，好的，快进到当前时间，所以你实际上是在我们深入探讨大语言模型（LLM）之前，让我们先谈谈这个。那么，什么是开发者关系倡导者，以及领导倡导者团队的人呢？那是什么工作？因为我们接下来要深入探讨很多技术内容。
And when people think of public relations, they think of speeches and writing speeches for candidates, these kind of things. But developer relations, you know, you're actually building a lot. So why don't you kind of give people a little bit of scaffold there? Yeah, okay. So for those folks who don't know the job or role of a developer advocate, basically, a developer advocate is somebody who they're advocating for developers, both in the product. So if you work for a company like saying, hey, we have these users
当人们想到公共关系时，他们会想到演讲和为候选人撰写演讲稿之类的东西。但开发者关系，你知道，你实际上是在构建很多东西。所以你为什么不给人们提供一点框架呢？好的。对于那些不知道开发者倡导者工作或角色的人来说，基本上，开发者倡导者是为开发者代言的人，既在产品内部。所以如果你为一家公司工作，比如，嘿，我们有这些用户
and they're trying to do things with their product, like let's actually help them out and build features which are going to be beneficial to them. But then also educating developers about new ways of doing things, new techniques, and kind of upskilling, helping them upskill. And the way I would describe a developer advocate, the most simple description is a developer advocate
他们正试图用我们的产品做一些事情，比如让我们真正帮助他们，构建对他们有益的功能。但同时也要教育开发者关于做事的新方法、新技术，并帮助他们提升技能。我描述开发者倡导者的方式，最简单的描述就是开发者倡导者
is a geek with social skills. So you have to be technical, you have to be able to write code, be up with the latest technologies and trends, and constantly learning, like picking up new technologies but you also you need to be like able to present able to do interviews like this to to kind of be very fluent so strong english skills like strong presentation skills those are all really important and um you can actually come up to be a developer advocate from either a highly technical role,
是一个有社交技能的极客。所以你必须具备技术能力，必须能够编写代码，了解最新的技术和趋势，并不断学习，比如掌握新技术，但你还需要能够进行演示，能够进行像这样的采访，能够非常流利，所以强大的英语能力和强大的演讲技巧都非常重要，而且嗯，你实际上可以从一个高度技术性的角色转变为开发者倡导者，
like a lot of developer advocates start their career as programmers and architects, and they get tired of just building things. They want to move up and actually be the change agent for industry and for folks who are adopting technology. So it's a great career path past, like what do you, what do you do when you're tired of just being the most technical person as
比如很多开发者倡导者开始他们的职业生涯时是程序员和架构师，他们厌倦了仅仅是构建东西。他们想要更进一步，真正成为行业和采用技术的人们的变革推动者。所以这是一个很棒的职业道路，比如当你厌倦了仅仅成为公司里技术最强的人时，你该做什么？
your company? On the other hand, you can also become a developer advocate by having great social skills and great kind of English language presentation skills. And one of the folks who I just hired, their name is Naya Macklin, also a speaker at SwampUp, got accepted before even joining my company.
另一方面，你也可以通过拥有出色的社交技能和出色的英语演讲技巧成为开发者倡导者。我刚雇佣的一位同事，她的名字叫 Naya Macklin，也是 SwampUp 的演讲者，在加入我公司之前就已经被录用了。
And they came up through a background of journalism and politics, kind of being involved in political campaigns, being involved in kind of all of that writing, outreach, campaigning, and wanted to move to a more technical role, wanted to move to something which was more technical. So they went to a back to a boot camp, kind of learned Python, JavaScript, all the basic skills, you know, all the way up to, you know, building web applications, like deploying technologies. They were developer advocate at Couchbase,
她有着新闻和政治背景，参与过政治竞选，参与过所有那些写作、外联、竞选活动，并希望转向一个更具技术性的角色，希望转向一些更具技术性的东西。所以她去参加了一个训练营，学习了 Python、JavaScript，所有基本技能，你知道，一直到构建 Web 应用程序、部署技术。她曾在 Couchbase 担任开发者倡导者，
now a developer advocate at Neo4j, and very early in their career. I would say that to be a developer advocate is not something that you have to be old and gray to be a good developer advocate. Some of the best developer advocates, actually most of the best developer advocates, mirror the audience. So if you're talking to a technical audience, you want to be
现在是 Neo4j 的开发者倡导者，而且职业生涯还处于早期阶段。我想说，成为开发者倡导者并不意味着你必须老态龙钟才能成为一名优秀的开发者倡导者。一些最优秀的开发者倡导者，实际上大多数最优秀的开发者倡导者，都能与受众产生共鸣。所以如果你在与技术受众交谈，你希望
able to just talk to them as peers. If you're going to a university and speaking to them, you want to be able to talk as a recent graduate. Kind of like being very close to the audience, I think, makes it more credible and makes you more effective in the role. Yeah, that makes sense. Very cool. Yeah, so folks out there, this is one of many really interesting professions that we're going to learn about here in these sessions. So if you have any questions about this or any other professions, you know, don't hesitate to shoot emails to us, post in the Discord. Feel free to kind of get that, keep that conversation going. There's a lot of really on discord um and uh feel free to join and be a part of that um okay so let's dive into llm so llm stands for large language model i think now they're starting to call them foundation models
能够像同行一样与他们交谈。如果你去大学与他们交谈，你希望能够像刚毕业的学生一样交谈。我认为与受众保持非常亲近的关系会使你更具可信度，并使你在角色中更有效。是的，这很有道理。非常酷。是的，所以各位，这是我们将在此次会议中了解到的众多非常有趣的职业之一。所以如果你对这个或任何其他职业有任何疑问，你知道，不要犹豫，给我们发电子邮件，在 Discord 上发帖。请随时保持对话。Discord 上有很多非常活跃的内容，嗯，欢迎加入并成为其中的一员，嗯，好的，让我们深入探讨 LLM，所以 LLM 代表大语言模型，我想现在他们开始称它们为基础模型
because you have vision and all these other modalities um but you know what is a large language model how would you describe that somebody yes i i think that this in the past has kind of required a technical explanation of like you know how you train the models and then how you how you can actually um build the models to to learn by feeding them extremely large data sets and then having them kind of iteratively complete the next word vector or or kind of the next idea in a chain of commands now actually it's much easier to explain this now because everyone's using it that's true yeah so if you're if you're using chat gpt if you're using copilot if if you're using any of these tools which kind of give you a language interface to talk to and interact with your code,
因为你有视觉和所有其他模态，嗯，但你知道什么是大语言模型，你会如何向别人描述它？是的，我认为过去这需要一种技术解释，比如你知道你是如何训练模型的，然后你如何实际上嗯构建模型，通过向它们输入极其庞大的数据集来学习，然后让它们以迭代的方式完成下一个词向量或链式命令中的下一个想法，现在实际上解释起来容易多了，因为每个人都在使用它，这是真的，是的，所以如果你正在使用 ChatGPT，如果你正在使用 Copilot，如果你正在使用任何这些为你提供语言界面来交谈并与你的代码交互的工具，
with the web, with an enterprise dataset, then you are using an LLM behind the scenes. And you can see that it's a very effective tool for a lot of tasks, which for humans are time-intensive and require a lot of knowledge entry, which require a lot of knowledge gaining. So it's great for summarizing information, great for writing emails. Excellent.
与 Web、与企业数据集交互，那么你就在幕后使用 LLM。你可以看到它对于许多任务来说是一个非常有效的工具，这些任务对人类来说是耗时的，需要大量的知识输入，需要大量的知识获取。所以它非常适合总结信息，非常适合撰写电子邮件。太棒了。
Don't recommend this at home for writing research papers. Not research papers, like class papers. Things which the professors say, oh, research this subject and then write a two or three page paper. It's amazing at that.
不建议在家里用它写研究论文。不是研究论文，而是课堂论文。教授说，哦，研究这个主题，然后写一篇两三页的论文。它在这方面非常出色。
But of course, completely against most schools' rules. That's right. Don't violate your school policy. It's really good at portmanteaus. You can say, give me a portmanteau of these two concepts, and you will come up with some incredibly brilliant names of companies. It's really good at that.
但当然，这完全违反了大多数学校的规定。没错。不要违反你的学校政策。它非常擅长合成词。你可以说，给我这两个概念的合成词，它会想出一些令人难以置信的绝妙公司名称。它在这方面真的很擅长。
Now, I would say what LLMs are poor or they don't have the a strong ability for is um in general they they don't reason like we do yeah so if the source material if the context is rich enough to to kind of piece together and give clues on on what the answer is it can both kind of pull from that body of knowledge, but then it can also synthesize information, which maybe is not clear from the very large, like they feed these systems with hundreds of billions of words and like huge unstructured document sets. And so it does kind of these amazing leaps which which seem like reasoning but they're not actually reasoning as humans think and reason and um also at a related
现在，我想说 LLM 不擅长或没有强大能力的地方是，嗯，总的来说，它们不像我们那样推理，是的，所以如果源材料、上下文足够丰富，可以拼凑在一起并提供关于答案是什么的线索，它既可以从那个知识库中提取，也可以综合信息，这可能在非常庞大的数据中并不清晰，比如他们用数千亿个单词和巨大的非结构化文档集来喂养这些系统。所以它确实做了一些惊人的飞跃，看起来像是推理，但它们实际上并不是人类思考和推理的那种推理，而且嗯，还有一个相关的
thing which they're poor at is is math right so in general like it's not you know they work as simple calculators and can answer basic math questions because again like that's all exists in the source material or they can specifically train the models and add in things for common questions which get asked so they they do a good job of calculating and returning a result via going to an agent or some other system which is specialized but in general they're not designed for math and if you give them a complex problem like I was playing around with one of these kind of online LM games where you're supposed to trick and
它不擅长的事情是数学，对吧？所以总的来说，你知道它们像简单的计算器一样工作，可以回答基本的数学问题，因为同样，这些都存在于源材料中，或者他们可以专门训练模型并为常见的被问到的问题添加内容，所以它们在计算和通过代理或其他专门系统返回结果方面做得很好，但总的来说，它们不是为数学设计的，如果你给它们一个复杂的问题，就像我正在玩这些在线 LLM 游戏之一，你需要欺骗和
hack the LM. Oh that's a thing? And it was kind of fun like they set it up as the LM thought it was a wizard and like it was protecting like some secrets and you were supposed to like convince it to protecting like some secrets and you were supposed to like convince
破解 LLM。哦，还有这种事？这很有趣，他们把它设置成 LLM 认为自己是一个巫师，它在保护一些秘密，而你应该说服它保护一些秘密，而你应该说服
it to give you the secrets and um basically they had multiple levels for difficulty where they add additional prompts which would prevent you from doing attacks which um will allow you to circumvent the lm but basically the way to the way to hack it is you did a combination of reasoning and hard math problems. So you'd ask it to, for example, do like a rough 13 algorithm or something complex, moderately complex,
它把秘密交给你，嗯，基本上他们设置了多个难度级别，他们添加了额外的提示，防止你进行攻击，嗯，这将允许你绕过 LLM，但基本上破解它的方法是你结合了推理和硬数学问题。所以你会要求它，例如，做一个粗略的 13 算法或一些复杂的、中等复杂的东西，
and basically you ask it to give you an answer, apply a math algorithm to it, and then the system which is checking the answer to make sure it's not revealing secrets now can't check the answer properly because you've encrypted it ah i see but when you look what you learn when you keep giving it harder and harder and harder math challenges is um it actually falls apart like it for example like rotation ciphers it'll consistently get the first few letters right it gets worse and worse and worse as it goes
基本上你要求它给你一个答案，应用一个数学算法，然后检查答案以确保它没有泄露秘密的系统现在无法正确检查答案，因为你已经加密了它，啊，我明白了，但当你不断给它越来越难的数学挑战时，你学到的是，嗯，它实际上会崩溃，比如旋转密码，它会始终如一地把前几个字母弄对，但随着它进行下去，它会变得越来越糟，
along because it gets lazy and it doesn't really care about the answer. I noticed if you tell it it's wrong, it'll get better. It's almost kind of like reinforcing an animal or something. It's like, oh, I'm so sorry, you're young, it'll get a little bit better.
因为它变得懒惰了，它并不真正关心答案。我注意到如果你告诉它错了，它会变得更好。这几乎就像强化动物一样。它就像，哦，我很抱歉，你很年轻，它会变得好一点。
And then the ultimate answer was to actually give it small snippets of code to generate or compile. Because again, the web is full of so much code. And those systems are also tuned for doing a certain amount of code challenges and problems. So the hardest reasoning problem you can give an LM actually is to do coding. So you combine that with like asking for some information or like trying to hide some information. You can actually trick it to do quite amazing things oh interesting so okay so you know i think that yeah when people
最终的答案实际上是给它生成或编译的小段代码。因为同样，Web 上充满了代码。这些系统也被调整为执行一定数量的代码挑战和问题。所以你能给 LLM 的最难的推理问题实际上是编码。所以你把它与要求一些信息或试图隐藏一些信息结合起来。你实际上可以欺骗它做一些相当惊人的事情，哦，有趣，所以好的，所以你知道，我认为是的，当人们
think of lms a lot of people have used chat gbt perplexity these other things and that's a pretty straightforward um from from like a product standpoint use case where you go to chatgbt.com and you're literally just a blank screen with a text box. You type what you want. And so it's the simplest product you can make. And it's because their technology is really impressive and they just want to focus on that.
想到 LLM 时，很多人都使用过 ChatGPT、Perplexity 等等，从产品角度来看，这是一个非常直接的用例，你访问 chatgpt.com，你实际上只是一个带有文本框的空白屏幕。你输入你想要的。所以这是你能制作的最简单的产品。这是因为他们的技术确实令人印象深刻，他们只想专注于此。
What are some other places, you know, maybe less obvious where LLMs are being used in the real world? Yeah, so I was mentioning things which lms aren't good at and an additional one which lms are not good at is um since they're trained on mostly public data they really know nothing about enterprise systems right nothing about ask it about your email things in your email for example yeah yeah and like similarly if you're if you're in a company which does um you know supply chain management of like parts and things for aircraft you can't ask it about like what's the part number or what's the what what parts do you
还有哪些地方，你知道，也许不那么明显，LLM 正在现实世界中使用？是的，所以我提到了 LLM 不擅长的事情，而 LLM 不擅长的另一个方面是，嗯，由于它们主要是在公共数据上训练的，它们对企业系统一无所知，对吧，对你的电子邮件中的事情一无所知，例如，是的，是的，同样，如果你在一家从事，你知道，飞机零件等供应链管理的公司，你不能问它关于零件编号是什么，或者你需要什么零件
need for a certain maintenance operation on a plane because that's just not something that's generally available to to lMs to be trained on. So one of the techniques you can do with LLMs is you can do something called retrieval augmented generation, where you feed in a body of this additional knowledge, additional information from, could be from a database, from a bunch of documents, from some other source which is not public. You embed it in a vector database. And then when you query the LM, you first query the vector database, the vector store.
用于飞机上的某种维护操作，因为这并不是 LLM 通常可以用来训练的东西。所以你可以用 LLM 做的一种技术叫做检索增强生成（RAG），你输入这些额外知识的主体，来自数据库、一堆文档、来自其他非公共来源的额外信息。你把它嵌入到向量数据库中。然后当你查询 LLM 时，你首先查询向量数据库，向量存储。
You ask it for information which relates to this. You pass that on to the LM as context. And now the LM, which is very, very good at answering abstract questions, now becomes an expert in this new data set and this new knowledge set. But with kind of the same limitations
你向它询问与此相关的信息。你将其作为上下文传递给 LLM。现在，非常擅长回答抽象问题的 LLM 变成了这个新数据集和新知识集的专家。但它有同样的局限性，
where it's not good at reasoning, it's not good at a whole bunch of things. And this produces another problem, which is, so getting back to the the aircraft example let's say let's say i'm a technician i need to perform maintenance on the the fuse lodge of an aircraft and i want to know like for for this particular aircraft model what what part number do i need to do this repair which i'm trying to execute. Now, if it's not exactly in the source
它不擅长推理，它不擅长很多事情。这产生了另一个问题，那就是，回到飞机示例，假设我是一名技术人员，我需要对飞机的机身进行维护，我想知道对于这个特定的飞机型号，我需要什么零件编号来执行我试图执行的维修。现在，如果它不在源材料中，
material, if maybe the relationship between the maintenance operations and the parts isn't clearly spelled out, the LM won't say, oh, I don't have that information. You should maybe talk to somebody who's done this before. What it's going to say is
如果维护操作和零件之间的关系没有明确说明，LLM 不会说，哦，我没有那个信息。你也许应该和以前做过这件事的人谈谈。它会说的是
it's going to say, oh, well, if you're doing this sort of operation, there's a number of different things which you could use for this. And I'll give you a list of different parts which are totally plausible. And I'll tell you any of these would work. Just go ahead and... Oh, man. I think you're explaining a lot about like Boeing doors falling off airplanes.
它会说，哦，好吧，如果你正在进行这种操作，有许多不同的东西你可以使用。我会给你一个完全合理的零件列表。我会告诉你这些中的任何一个都可以。直接去做吧……哦，天哪。我想你解释了很多关于波音舱门从飞机上掉下来的原因。
I hope they're not using theMs for their maintenance on Boeing planes. But you can see that it's for enterprise use. You can actually get pretty far with an LM, but it has problems with what we're currently referring to as hallucinations.
我希望他们没有在波音飞机的维护中使用 LLM。但你可以看到，对于企业使用，你实际上可以用 LLM 走得很远，但它存在我们目前称为幻觉的问题。
Basically, the model will extrapolate information, which may or may not be true. And depending upon how good the source information is, how good the encoding is, you can get to some customer support systems, they get to maybe 60%, 70% accuracy or accepted answers
基本上，模型会推断出可能正确也可能不正确的信息。根据源信息的好坏、编码的好坏，你可以得到一些客户支持系统，它们可能达到 60%、70% 的准确率或被接受的答案，
when a customer support representative looks at this and says, is this the right answer to give a customer? But the question is, when you get to that accuracy, let's say you get to 80% or 90% accuracy, is that good enough for aircraft maintenance, for supply chain management, for fraud detection? There's a whole bunch of critical use cases. Is that good enough? Is that accuracy good enough? and then the second question is if when it's wrong how do i know it's wrong how do i
当客户支持代表看到这一点并说，这是给客户的正确答案吗？但问题是，当你达到那个准确率时，假设你达到 80% 或 90% 的准确率，这对飞机维护、供应链管理、欺诈检测来说足够好吗？有很多关键用例。这足够好吗？那个准确率足够好吗？然后第二个问题是，当它出错时，我怎么知道它错了，我怎么
how do i check the system how do i explain how it got the results so um this this is actually the subject of my talk which is there is there's another way which you can um encode enterprise information, which has been in use for a while. It's called knowledge graphs or property graphs, basically the same thing. And a lot of expert systems will use knowledge graphs as the system of truth for capturing data, kind of building expert systems. But the typical problem with those is to build an expert system on top of a knowledge graph, you need an interface. So you need to build an application,
我怎么检查系统，我怎么解释它是如何得到结果的？所以，嗯，这实际上是我演讲的主题，即还有另一种方法可以，嗯，编码企业信息，这种方法已经使用了一段时间。它被称为知识图谱或属性图，基本上是一回事。许多专家系统将使用知识图谱作为捕获数据的真理系统，类似于构建专家系统。但这些系统的典型问题是，要在知识图谱之上构建专家系统，你需要一个界面。所以你需要构建一个应用程序，
you have to have a bunch of queries and drop-down menus and things for people to find information. So wouldn't it be nice if you could ask the LM, but then have it give you information from a knowledge graph instead of just randomly pulling information out of a vector store and so this technique for pairing knowledge graphs and lms together is called graph rag it's a really effective way of improving the accuracy of your results there was a study recently done i believe by by gartner where they
你必须有一堆查询和下拉菜单以及人们查找信息的东西。所以如果你能询问 LLM，但让它从知识图谱中给你信息，而不是仅仅从向量存储中随机提取信息，那不是很好吗？所以这种将知识图谱和 LLM 配对在一起的技术被称为 GraphRAG，这是提高结果准确性的一种非常有效的方法，最近有一项研究，我相信是由 Gartner 完成的，他们
showed a 54 increase in accuracy just by switching to knowledge graphs versus like traditional vector stores oh okay um it makes it easier to explain the results because part of the knowledge graph gets passed into the lms context and knowledge graphs unlike um vector databases actually you can you can reason about them you can see what are the nodes or the actually you can reason about them. You can see what are the nodes, what are the relationships. You can actually start to understand why the LM was giving a correct or incorrect answer and then go back to the source data and fix it. So is the LM translating your English request into a knowledge graph query? Is that how it's working?
显示，仅仅通过切换到知识图谱而不是传统的向量存储，准确率就提高了 54%，哦，好的，嗯，这使得解释结果变得更容易，因为知识图谱的一部分被传递到 LLM 的上下文中，而且知识图谱与向量数据库不同，实际上你可以推理它们，你可以看到节点是什么，或者实际上你可以推理它们。你可以看到节点是什么，关系是什么。你实际上可以开始理解为什么 LLM 给出了正确或错误的答案，然后回到源数据并修复它。所以 LLM 是在把你的英语请求翻译成知识图谱查询吗？它是这样工作的吗？
Or is it just more fundamentally integrated with the knowledge graph? Yeah, so it's doing a couple things. So when you take the source material and you put it inside of a graph database that also supports vector search, it's
还是它与知识图谱更根本地集成在一起？是的，所以它在做几件事。所以当你获取源材料并将其放入也支持向量搜索的图数据库中时，它
doing a standard vector encoding using word vectors of the embeddings. It's also using an LLm to create a graph and you can you can you can hand make a knowledge graph you can also tweak the knowledge the resulting knowledge graph but a really quick way of doing this is to actually use an llm to generate the knowledge graph off the source material as well and once you have a knowledge graph plus the vector database and linkages between them, now you can
正在使用嵌入的词向量进行标准向量编码。它还使用 LLM 来创建图，你可以，你可以，你可以手工制作知识图谱，你也可以调整知识图谱，生成的知识图谱，但实现这一点的非常快的方法实际上是使用 LLM 从源材料中生成知识图谱。一旦你有了知识图谱加上向量数据库以及它们之间的链接，现在你就可以
basically feed it into the vector store, the question, get back some embeddings, see what nodes they're associated with and pull the related nodes, and then feed that all as context into the LLM.
基本上把它输入到向量存储中，问题，取回一些嵌入，看看它们与哪些节点相关联并提取相关节点，然后将所有这些作为上下文输入到 LLM 中。
And so basically it's a better vector search because it's vector search which includes knowledge graphs and real data coming from the lm yeah that is super cool okay so um to have folks deployed graph rag uh you know different industries and and tell us maybe a good story, bad story kind of thing. What's something maybe hilarious that came out of it? And what's also something where at scale
所以基本上它是一个更好的向量搜索，因为它是包含知识图谱和来自 LLM 的真实数据的向量搜索，是的，这太酷了，好的，所以，嗯，让人们部署 GraphRAG，你知道，不同的行业，给我们讲一个好的故事，坏的故事之类的。有什么搞笑的事情发生吗？还有什么地方，在大规模情况下，
you had an aha moment or a eureka moment? I think a lot of our customers are using GraphRag and graph databases specifically to solve the problem of getting higher accuracy on RAG. Some of our customers are using it for, in particular, customer service systems.
你有一个顿悟时刻或尤里卡时刻？我认为我们的许多客户正在使用 GraphRAG 和图数据库专门解决在 RAG 上获得更高准确性的问题。我们的一些客户正在使用它，特别是用于客户服务系统。
That's one of the common scenarios. A second one in general is recommendation engines. Oh, that makes sense. So trying to give back better search results, better recommendations to end users. And actually, we had an interesting use case
这是常见的场景之一。第二个通常是推荐引擎。哦，这很有道理。所以试图给最终用户提供更好的搜索结果，更好的推荐。实际上，我们有一个有趣的用例，
where this is a different use of LLMs. It still generally falls under GraphRack, but it's more of a research system than it is a query system where um one of our customers um maintains oil fields and kind of that oil infrastructure and um you know making sure that the the supply chain is uninterrupted is important for them
这是 LLM 的不同用途。它仍然通常属于 GraphRAG，但它更像是一个研究系统，而不是一个查询系统，其中，嗯，我们的一位客户，嗯，维护油田和那种石油基础设施，而且，你知道，确保供应链不中断对他们来说很重要，
but there's so many data points in terms of conditions and maintenance issues and weather conditions that it becomes very hard to even understand root cause analysis on why things are getting delayed or slowed down so what they did is they they fed huge amounts of data into an llm using using a using a graph representation of this, using a graph store, and then had the LLM start to reason and give some potential answers about where the issues were with outages
但在条件、维护问题和天气条件方面有太多的数据点，以至于很难理解为什么事情会被延迟或减慢的根本原因分析，所以他们所做的是，他们使用这种图表示，使用图存储，将大量数据输入到 LLM 中，然后让 LLM 开始推理并给出一些关于停电问题所在位置的潜在答案，
or supply chain issues or things in there, and got some interesting insights. Now, it's a humongous model, very slow to load up the massive quantities of data and things which they did. But from a research standpoint, they got some really valuable insights, which would have required a humongous amount of human manpower and research to actually go through the data and build those insights. So I think there's a variety of different use cases for it.
或供应链问题或其中的事情，并获得了一些有趣的见解。现在，这是一个巨大的模型，加载他们所做的大量数据和东西非常慢。但从研究的角度来看，他们获得了一些非常有价值的见解，如果通过数据并构建这些见解，将需要大量的人力和研究。所以我认为它有各种不同的用例。
And I'd say the biggest challenge, and those are all successful production-ready systems I talked about, but the biggest challenge in the white elephant in the room related to LMs and, in general, Gen AI architectures, is it's all startups and very little is in production. So when you actually get down to it and you're like,
我想说最大的挑战，我谈到的那些都是成功的生产就绪系统，但最大的挑战，与 LLM 和总的来说 Gen AI 架构相关的房间里的大象，是它全是初创公司，很少有投入生产的。所以当你真正深入研究它，并且你像，
okay, well, how many people are using Langchain or Alama or these models in production? And they're like, oh, we have a really promising system and we're getting the accuracy up and we're almost there. But I think a lot of folks are almost there and are kind of looking for the technology to mature.
好的，好吧，有多少人在生产中使用 Langchain 或 Ollama 或这些模型？他们说，哦，我们有一个非常有前途的系统，我们正在提高准确性，我们快要成功了。但我认为很多人都快要成功了，并且正在寻找技术成熟。
And also for the cost to be reasonable as well. I think that it doesn't... Doing research and doing development in LLMsms it makes sense because the technology is not that expensive to prototype with when we were doing at scale large volumes of data a huge amount of resources and processing and gpus which you need to to then execute the
而且成本也要合理。我认为它不会……在 LLM 中进行研究和开发是有意义的，因为当我们在大规模处理大量数据时，原型设计的技术并不那么昂贵，大量的资源和处理以及 GPU，你需要这些来执行
the building of knowledge graphs or in general building of RAG and search on RAG, that can be quite expensive. So I think also enterprise use cases are a great place where the benefit-cost trade-off makes a lot of sense. If you're just doing like this for a general consumer system, you don't want everyone just firing off queries randomly unless you have a huge amount of capital like OpenAI. But if you're in a corporate system where it's customers doing queries
构建知识图谱或总的来说构建 RAG 和 RAG 上的搜索，这可能非常昂贵。所以我认为企业用例也是一个很好的地方，利益成本权衡非常有意义。如果你只是为一个通用消费者系统做这个，除非你有像 OpenAI 那样的大量资本，否则你不想让每个人都随机发出查询。但如果你在一个企业系统中，有客户在进行查询，
and they're solving business problems, then it makes a lot of sense that I can pay the token fees and everything, but then it's saving me and my customers time and money because we're able to get answers faster and easier than we would if we were going through a human workforce that makes sense and so just uh kind of one last question on the theme of ml ops you know if someone wants to uh you know go into the ml ops kind of profession um you know what is your kind of uh best advice for them um you know let's say they are um um
并且他们正在解决业务问题，那么我支付代币费用和一切是非常有意义的，但它正在为我和我的客户节省时间和金钱，因为我们能够比通过人类劳动力更快、更容易地获得答案，这很有道理，所以只是，嗯，关于 ML Ops 主题的最后一个问题，你知道，如果有人想，嗯，进入 ML Ops 这种职业，你知道，你对他们有什么最好的建议，嗯，让我们假设他们是，嗯，嗯，
you know they they're they're just finishing high school and they have a choice between you know getting a four-year degree going into a boot camp should they try and get a degree really kind of specific on on uh you know uh um it ops or just a you know general computer science or even a general math degree how do you feel like folks should kind of navigate that yeah no i think that it's there's there's a lot of great options for like technology degrees um just despite what what folks say including shulmi benheim in the keynote stay SwampUp, developer jobs aren't at risk. I think that AI technology continues to build and create new opportunities and new technical challenges
你知道，他们刚高中毕业，他们面临选择，你知道，获得四年制学位，去参加训练营，他们应该尝试获得一个真正具体的学位，关于，嗯，IT Ops，还是一个通用的计算机科学，甚至是一个通用的数学学位，你觉得人们应该如何导航？是的，不，我认为有很多很棒的技术学位选择，尽管人们怎么说，包括 SwampUp 主题演讲中的 Shlomi Ben-Haim，开发者工作并没有风险。我认为人工智能技术继续构建并创造新的机会和新的技术挑战，
that you need really smart people to solve. And my best advice for folks would be the real skill set you need to learn in college is how to solve hard problems. And so if you feel challenged, if you're in a degree program or if you're taking something where you feel like
你需要非常聪明的人来解决。我给人们最好的建议是，你在大学里需要学习的真正技能是如何解决难题。所以如果你感到受到挑战，如果你在学位课程中，或者如果你正在学习一些让你觉得
you're learning new material, you're able to use your expertise to solve problems, to reason about things to to make a difference that skill set the the ability to understand pick up a new challenge reason about it lms don't reason humans do right and and actually come up with some creative solutions that's what's going to be the valuable skill set going forward. And maybe we're not going to be sitting there
你正在学习新材料，你能够利用你的专业知识来解决问题，对事情进行推理，做出改变，那种技能，理解、接受新挑战、对其进行推理的能力，LLM 不会推理，人类会，对吧，并且实际上提出一些创造性的解决方案，这就是未来有价值的技能。也许我们不会坐在那里
and coding basic algorithms for doing list sorting and all that stuff in the future. I mean, hopefully people aren't doing that other than like programming one-on-one because machines are better at that and they're better at optimizing those things than we are. But hopefully we're the ones who are actually taking the real world problems
并在未来编写用于列表排序等的基本算法。我的意思是，希望人们除了编程 101 之外不做这些，因为机器在这方面更好，而且它们在优化这些事情方面比我们更好。但希望我们是那些真正解决现实世界问题的人，
figuring out how to solve the hard problems and actually ml ops is a great example of this because figuring out how to observe how to secure and how to make sure that machine learning models are being taken from the developer all the way through to production is a hard problem and a machine isn't going to solve this for us this is something which you need people who understand the problem they understand the space they can do it actually even my talk here at SwampUp is about using one of the tools in that tool chain Artifactory which you can use as a model repository pulling information out of it feeding it into a knowledge graph using the Neo4j Knowledge Graph Builder.
弄清楚如何解决难题，实际上 ML Ops 就是一个很好的例子，因为弄清楚如何观察、如何保护以及如何确保机器学习模型从开发者一直到生产都被采用是一个难题，机器不会为我们解决这个问题，这是你需要了解问题、了解空间、能够做到这一点的人，实际上我在 SwampUp 的演讲也是关于使用该工具链中的工具之一 Artifactory，你可以将其用作模型存储库，从中提取信息，将其输入到知识图谱中，使用 Neo4j 知识图谱构建器。
And in a couple hours on a weekend or an afternoon, you can basically have your own LLM with enterprise information from your machine learning pipeline and then start asking questions like, oh, which dependencies have an MIT license on them? Or what's the latest version of this library? You can start asking your own little system
在周末或下午的几个小时里，你基本上可以拥有自己的 LLM，其中包含来自你的机器学习管道的企业信息，然后开始问诸如，哦，哪些依赖项具有 MIT 许可证？或者这个库的最新版本是什么？你可以开始问你自己的小系统
these questions. Cool. So I think that it's an exciting time for folks who are in technology professions because if you're able to learn to reason and to create and understand new problems and new challenges, then you'll have pretty much work no matter what field or degree program you go into. totally agree um cool it's awesome having you here um at at a swap up here at austin and uh i look forward to chatting with you later on thank you so much for uh entertaining the folks yeah no thanks for having me on the show and i'd love to join the um discussion on discord as well
这些问题。酷。所以我认为对于从事技术职业的人来说，这是一个激动人心的时刻，因为如果你能够学习推理、创造并理解新问题和新挑战，那么无论你进入什么领域或学位课程，你基本上都会有工作。完全同意，嗯，酷，很高兴你来到这里，在奥斯汀的 SwampUp，我期待稍后与你聊天。非常感谢你招待大家，是的，不，谢谢你邀请我参加节目，我也很乐意加入 Discord 上的讨论，
cool that'd be great we'll look forward to it Thank you. And share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
酷，那太好了，我们期待着。谢谢。并分享同类。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。